all right so I am late uh traffic is a
little slow today
will open up our public hearing
Senate Bill 31 and here from our Prime
sponsor
representative Senator Susie good
committee for the record I'm Donna soucy
I represent Senate District 18 comprised
of the town of Litchfield and five Wards
in the city of Manchester and I'm here
today introducing Senate Bill 31 on
behalf of the insurance department
Senate field 31 makes several technical
changes to the law administered by the
insurance department and these include
to permit third party administrators
tpas that cannot meet licensing
requirements for either net worth or
audited financial statements to post a
bond instead
modernized language and RSA 412 colon 6
which regulates forms and rates for
Property and Casualty Insurance this
change clarifies excuse me Senator
please talk into the microphone thank
you
this change clarifies the insurer's
obligations and deletes unnecessary
language in that statute further it
clarifies the registration requirements
in relation to Consumer guarantee
contracts for Property and Casualty
Insurance this change to the statute
requires insurers to register if they're
going to sell consumer guarantee
contracts the change would allow the
department to track the exact number of
companies who are selling these
contracts it updates in an accurate RSA
reference in RSA 420 J colon 5 and
lastly makes amendments to the statute
on federal health care reform the change
to RSA 420n will clarify the
Department's primary regulatory
authority over Insurance reforms
implemented by the Affordable Care Act
also extends to amendments to the ACA
and related laws Heather Silverstein
from the insurance department is here
and I think can answer your more
technical questions should you have them
but as always I remain open to questions
Mr chairman and appreciate the
opportunity to be here thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee members see none thank you
even though I know you wrote such a
wonderful thing there for Senator Susie
to read I'm sure there's more detail
that you would love to go through
my name is Heather Silverstein I'm
general counsel at the New Hampshire
insurance department uh yes thank you
senator soucy for introducing our bill
today uh we uh this is a technical bill
you know as we practice at the
department and we are in the statutes
and we use the statute so we apply the
statutes there's times that we realize
something is either out of date or not
working or confusing so this bill is our
effort to try to get some of the
language in our statutes up to date and
make it more clear that's the overall
premise of this particular bill with
regard to third party administrators
we're permitting a bond this is an
unusual situation it would be instead of
the normal Financial requirements
um the the it's in the situation
according to our financial director is
unusual but if a TPA was doing work for
an unlicensed insurance company that
would be the situation and they wanted a
license in New Hampshire so they wanted
a TPA license in New Hampshire and so um
he feels comfortable with the posting of
the bond in those situations so that's
why we're adding that language
the RSA 4126 with regard to Property and
Casualty contracts the language was
confusing confusing with regard to
prepayment of judgments and we didn't
want the language in there to make it
seem like whether the insured could pay
or not was a condition related to the
contract that is not you know something
that we would want as a condition in
there so we cleaned that up like we
needed we needed that to be more clear
with regard to RSA 415c our consumer
guarantee contracts
we want to know
who is registered to sell them and
currently in New Hampshire we don't know
all the players and so this these
changes here make it so that we know
everybody that is selling these in New
Hampshire and that's important for us
because if we want to at some point
maybe do an exam or do exams on these
particular entities we know who's
registered here so this is what this
language did
um to clean up 415c and then the last
couple of changes were really like
correcting a typo with regard to 420 J5
in relation to annual reports the annual
report reference and then under
um 420n you know just making it clear
that even if there's amendments to the
Affordable Care Act or other health
insurance related federal laws that we
are the primary regulator and we would
be the ones reviewing the forms related
to those laws so that's what this bill
does
okay uh the only question I have again
is the Surplus line so this is we're
trying to identify the people rather
than the the product right the product
still has to be submitted to the
department and and I know we have I
think I sponsored the legislation for
the instant instant uh approval of of a
submitted product but just this is the
people who are actually selling it
exactly okay so we wanted to make that
clear that we want to know everybody
that's selling
okay any other questions from committee
members seeing them thank you very much
thank you very much
okay is there anybody else who would
like to
speak on
okay
the public hearing on Senate Bill 82 and
hear from the prime sponsor Senator
Susie
good morning again Senator good morning
Mr chairman and committee members once
again Donna soucy representing Senate
District 18.
this time here on Senate Bill 82
relative to prompt payment for managed
care
this bill merely attempts to ensure that
claims that are are processed in a
timely manner
providers here in New Hampshire have
experienced delays in getting claims
fully adjudicated processed and paid
according to the current statute and the
delay has resulted in accounts
receivable for providers well beyond 90
days from the date of service what this
delay does is impacts patients when you
receive one of those this is not a bill
explanation of benefit forms from the
carrier with the final balance due after
insurance payment those are not issued
in a timely manner if those are not
being resolved in a timely manner you as
a consumer a patient don't recognize
what you owe
as part of provision of service based on
the insurance coverage that you have so
what the bill attempts to do is reduce
or eliminate some of the ongoing issues
of unresolved processing of claims and
if the carriers have denied or suspended
a claim requested and received the
additional information from the provider
then this bill provides that the claim
needs to be adjudicated within 45 days
after 45 days if the carrier fails to
act fails to request additional
information or provide reason for
disputed payment the claim would be
treated as clean and then paid
and that is
essentially the issue Mr chairman is to
make sure that if the carriers are
providing coverage and as long as the
providers of service are providing the
necessary information to and clean claim
is a term of art that's used in the
statute um
these these bills do get paid and then
we as consumers can pay our share as
well to the extent we are required based
on our own individual plans
be happy to take any questions I know
there are folks here from the industry
as well as from the hospital Association
that will speak to you about more
specific instances where this has
occurred and has really led to
um
concern and the reason for the bill
we do have a question yes representative
Terry thank you could you just give us a
uh a real world a hypothetical example
of what you've just described
well
um I I did not bring any of my own
medical bills with me but I
interestingly enough that you asked that
question
um last November not November of 23
November of 21 I fell and injured my
knee
and I went to Urgent Care the time I did
it
this
past November November of 22
I received a statement and I
kind of scratched my head because I
couldn't figure out what it was
referring to and I looked at it a second
time when I did I realized it was the
claim from a year ago that was finally
being resolved now at that point I have
a plan with a deductible so I had
already satisfied my deductible
but it it was left hanging I don't I
don't know the reason that it hadn't
been resolved but the entity that
provided me care that day in November of
did not receive payment from my carrier
until November of the following year
and that's the kind of situation we're
trying to avoid to the extent that all
of the proper information to make the
claim a clean claim has been satisfied
follow please for the question so
so you had an incident in November of 21
and then in November of 22 you receive a
bill
from the provider
the Urgent Care no no no what I received
was a statement
from my insurer saying that they had
paid the claim yes
because I have a deductible of two
thousand dollars that had already been
satisfied because of other services I
did not owe anything additionally but
the provider had not been paid until
that time
and what we're trying to do is ensure
that those claims that have the
appropriate information provided to the
insurer just get paid in a timely
fashion we just want them to pay what
they have negotiated
with the carrier as with the providers
and pay those bills which they did but
not in a timely fashion correct thank
you
representative Burroughs
yes thank you for taking my question I
was wondering what the average time is
if you know to adjudicate these um
claims
um representative Burroughs I think
there are people who will testify after
me it might be better suited to answer
the question off my own experience I
couldn't give you a good answer
follow-up for the question again it
might be people coming after you but do
you know what the obstacles have been in
terms of why like your claim that you
talk about took so long
um in in my specific instance it's
unclear to me why it did take so long
there I know have been some changes some
of the carriers have changed computer
systems that has caused delays there are
from time to time delays because a
carrier fails to provide sufficient
information so that you know once again
would you know renew the clock and and
give uh excuse me the provider failed to
provide sufficient information
um
but we do know and as I said you will
hear testimony um particularly from the
hospital Association what is happening
is sometimes it can take 90 days 120
days I attended a legislative breakfast
of a Manchester Hospital this past week
and they have outstanding claims of more
than a million six uh that are well over
120 days so what that does to The Entity
is then it makes it harder for them in
turn to pay their bills and we're just
looking for
uh a little more efficiency and
timeliness of payment
so uh Senator before you go uh jog my
memory I feel like we just did this
legislation not so long ago about the
timely payments so am I crazy or you
don't remember
um we we may have done other legislation
Mr Church yeah we remember but
but tell you that there is an ongoing
issue that
so and then the way I read the bill is
they they have these dates if you put in
45 days but
um
it but I see that that within 15 days
supposed to Mclean 30 days upon receipt
and then and then processing and
explaining why it's not paid timely then
and you scratch out if the required
notice is not provided
so uh I'm not sure what the consequence
of taking that phrase out but all I see
is that it fails to provide required
notice but that which is
saying the same thing right it fails to
require the dose we just said if the
requirement is not provided so it just
seems a little bizarre and then we have
a new date a new number thrown in here
and and I just wasn't sure how that
follows with the 15 and the 30 days that
are already in the statute well once
again the the
FIP out submission of the claim
to be clear we're taking out the
required notice part and expanding on it
to be sure that it's clear that the
carrier has to provide notice and their
failure to do so
within 45 days we're trying to give a
decent window of time to resolve the
claim
results in it being deemed clean clean
and their need to pay
but Jory they've already says that they
need to make a notice of why they're not
paying it
they had as long as the statutes is
saying you give us the reasoning
and then you're just repeating the same
thing
but now you have this penalty is that if
if you didn't if they if whatever notice
they got they didn't get it or they
didn't see it or they didn't but now all
of a sudden you're gonna they're gonna
call up and say now you've got to pay it
and the insurance company is going to
say what do you mean you got to pay it
we're in compliance because we can
comply with the first part
chairman I think what we are trying to
do is make more explicit that the
carrier has an obligation to adjudicate
the claim within the 45 days and failure
to do so I think this just makes the
language more Express because as I said
this although we have you're right I
think I'm not sure how many years ago
have been looking at this statute
there is still a problem with long
outstanding claims without adequate
notice to the provider of how to resolve
them and it's resulting in burden on the
providers right so but basically this is
I guess the key word in this case is
adjudicate in other words you you're
expecting that within 45 days this thing
is going to get solved
unless
unless the carrier requires additional
information and provides notice
right but that was already required
before 30 days
so in this case it it implies that even
if they did give Carter more information
it doesn't matter at 45 days it's got to
be adjudicated because they've already
give the notice or the explanation of
why it wasn't paid on time
but all right we'll we'll review this in
in committee we'll have a subcommittee
on it yeah
[Music]
yes I don't know how many exchanges they
had with the provider
um the
that I uh went to
um but yes they would have because they
needed to provide notice of the reason
that they are failing to pay the claim
and absent doing so it should be deemed
clean and they should have paid
okay representative Gibbs you have a
question
okay
correct
and then uh from the question uh
the requirements is that the ensure
notify the health care provider for
public portion of the reason for denying
or that this problem is explained
uh my question is and and I'm going to
um uh my question is did you consider
we're going to get to the inter
shall notify both the provider and the
covered position of the problem and the
when I received a bill to 37 000 from
the hospital uh because I have Medicare
part A but not Part B because I kept my
employer providers provided
foreign
and the hospital was not provided all
the information that was needed uh to
about the dollar bill so I had no idea
of this until I received the third and
seven thousand dollar bill which was
about
six or seven most active surgery
God
died
okay let's let her answer the question
okay but my point is that if they had no
replies
both through Survivor and
so thanks for that question
representative Gibbs no I didn't
consider that I mean that's certainly
something that I think the committee and
its wisdom could consider because you
are right there are times that um
perhaps intervening as the patient
particularly
for those of us that have a deductible
to meet earlier in time you want to
resolve those issues and hopefully get
them paid so that may make sense to uh
have those of us who are patients uh
intervene and assist with trying to
resolve these claims more quickly but I
leave that to the committee
okay
I guess we're all set thank you thank
you very much Mr okay chair we'll call
him Paula menahan from the New Hampshire
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Paula
manyhansen your vice president state
government relations with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals in the
state we are in strong support of
senability too and we do appreciate
Senator Souci sponsoring this bill as
well as all the co-sponsors with
bipartisan support this does amend the
prompt pay statute slightly we did ask
Senator Susie to put this bill in
um and the reason
um I think she did a great job
explaining why we need it but it is to
ensure ultimately that the health care
claims that are submitted to the
carriers are in fact processed in a
timely manner and unfortunately our
hospitals have experienced ongoing
delays in having claims processed in a
timely manner so what 82 does is merely
clarify when the carrier either denies
or suspends which is the current um
statute we don't have the entire Statute
in the bill would just amending a
certain part of that statute that the
carrier receives the additional
information that they are that was
requested from the hospital or the
health care
provider they must adjudicate within the
45 days and the problem is if they don't
adjudicate what happens because that's
the that's kind of the loophole if you
will right now they don't adjudicate
within 45 days so what we did was we
took existing statute and chairman hunt
you did identify that right now it says
if the required notice is not provided
well that's not necessarily the issue
what we did was we took that and we just
changed that that language we remove
that and then we just added if the
health carrier either fails to provide
required notice or and the new languages
to adjudicate the claim within 45
calendar days of receipt of additional
information that's the new language so
we're just saying you have all the
requirements before and then if you
don't do it within 45 days then it
becomes a clean claim which I think
representative Gibbs articulated so
that's really what this does this has
um the claims the delays in claims
processing as Senator Susie said does
cause much confusion for patients as um
because the claims are not processed in
a timely manner the responsibility the
patient responsibility determine it is
many months later results in confusion
they get the EOB or the explanation of
benefits from the carrier then the
patient responsibility balance due from
the provider is sent and confusion
ensues so on behalf of the hospitals and
the patients that we care for we do
strongly urge you to support this bill
and I'm happy to answer any questions I
do can I just answer the comment or
question that representative Gibbs had
relative to
sending bills at the same time I think
that could cause even more confusion and
I believe I don't see the contracts
between the providers and the carriers
but I don't believe they're allowed to
bill the patient you don't you don't
send a bill to a patient it would just
really cause confusion um so it's really
waiting for the processing and then
whatever the balance is due
um and I think in this case it was a um
a case of not of not having the provider
not having all the information on all
the insurer Insurance
um plans that um perhaps you had at the
time so um so that that is a
coordination of benefits because
typically they would know if you have
part A and a supplemental then they
would know to Bill Medicare first and
then the supplemental follows so
um that I think was just a case of not
having all the additional all the
information that unfortunately that they
needed I I don't believe
um sending a bill to the patient would
help I think it could actually cause
more confusion because we don't want
patients paying for claims that are
covered by Insurance
um but that's so that's not what we're
asking we're just asking that these be
processed in a timely manner so happy to
answer any questions
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um
well this is really a a follow-up
comment um so would you believe or the
question okay would you believe yes uh
would you believe that I was not asking
that anyone send me a bill which however
they eventually did uh for a uh a
payment that was actually owed by Blue
Cross
um and yes it was a coordination of
benefits problem but I had in fact
provided to them with all the
information they just had not recorded
it correctly and this is what they told
me they had not recorded it correctly
and therefore had not provided all the
information either to Medicare or to
Blue Cross and therefore Medicare and
Blue Cross were just passing it back and
forth both refusing to pay it which then
as I said six or seven months later
resulted in them sending me a bill which
in fact I did not owe so what I was
suggesting was not that anybody send me
a bill which I wish they had not done
but they did anyway but rather that they
send but what I was suggesting and I
guess my question is then do you see a
problem with this uh send a notice to
the patient that there's a problem
because it was only when I got involved
that okay so I think I think we got it
was resolved I think we got it I think
the problem with that yeah yes
yeah
would you believe it could just be yes
um I I Healthcare is very complicated
and insurance billing is really
complicated so I do believe that um
there was a error um and I I am hopeful
that it got resolved in a um in a
positive manner that um you were um that
you were satisfied with okay
representative Terry has another
question thank you so I I love these
terms that that we get uh on a routine
basis
um and and the term here is clean claim
in distinction I presume to dirty claim
but I don't think that's what you mean
clean versus dirty but that the term is
not defined here so one so I just want
you to be sure here that clean actually
means that there's no more no more
information that's going to be requested
or provided there's no more anything it
just becomes finalized that is it's all
finished and you have to pay the claim
right thank you for the question
um and yes these um terms are defined so
if you go to
420j8 small a prompt pay request so go
to go to the definitions there is a
definition of clean claim and it is and
it is means a claim for payment of
covered health care expenses that is
submitted to a health carrier on the
carrier's standard claim form using the
most current Pub published procedural
codes with all the required Fields
completed with correct and complete
information in accordance with the
carriers published filing requirements I
believe I'm going to age myself but I
believe I was involved in this back in
2000 when this um bill and I believe
chairman hunt was here too so I believe
that's when this this original prompeii
law was passed back in 2000. so there
so to clarify the answer is yes no more
Dilly Dowling around no more Dilly
dallying thank you yes yeah we like that
term too and you can use that and you
can use that when you get out of the
any other questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you
okay uh
yeah
okay Deborah uh cats
the Pembroke Wellness Center in support
good morning good morning my name is
Deborah Cates
I am
um a registered nurse practice manager
billing manager for Pembroke Wellness
Center
which is one of the few independent
um let's see and I've excuse me I'm not
this is the second time I've done this
in the past months for something
um in relationship to medical stuff
um let's see here I've been employed at
Pembroke Wellness Center for over 25
years and I've been doing billing for
Pembroke Wellness Center for 20 years so
I am very well versed
in the medical billing world because
that's how we survive as an independent
practice at Pembroke Wellness Center my
husband sold the practice just three
four months ago to another independent
physician Dr Jennifer McKenzie I am in
very strong support of SB 82 as a family
practice office we don't usually deal
with large-scale claims meaning volume
as large numbers but recently
um
I had a claim deny with no reason behind
this denial code which was denial code
co45 which I'll just quickly read that
it meant charges exceed your contractual
legislative fee Arrangement note this
adjusted amount cannot equal the total
service charge amount basically the line
item just denied and it happened to be a
line item that was over one thousand
dollars which in our field in my family
practice office we never bill out
thousand dollar claims except this
particular
item that we were doing or dealing with
was a medical device that we were using
on a particular patient
thank goodness in our office we can um
uh bill on um uh ordering I had 90 days
to pay for this particular item because
we actually in our small office our
checkbook only runs ten to twenty
thousand dollars maximum at any given
time so having to pay for an item that
cost a thousand dollars and having the
insurance company deny said item
um the claim was submitted to the
insurance company clean there was zero
errors on the claim so I had been
watching this particular claim the
patient was seen on January 25th it was
billed clean electronically on the 25th
I received a partial payment on 220
meaning three of the line items totally
paid clean the actual device denied no
idea why I had to pick up the phone on
221 most places would not notice that
that but I was watching because I needed
that money to come through our door
I called and they said huh don't know
why
we'll resubmit it to X Y and Z insurance
company I called again on 321 still
waiting for my payment to come through
the door it did pay on 328 but it did
require
my person to pay me
what amounted to be almost an hour's
worth of time on a phone just getting a
line item paid that should never have
not paid
the other interesting thing to me was
there was Zero interest that came with
this line item that should have been
paid cleanly straight out the door but
hey
um
let's see
that's pretty much it on that so
thank you for your time
I know Paula minahan
[Laughter]
but we appreciate having a real life
example
thank you very much for coming
I have one card left uh Sabrina Dunlap
from anthem
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'll be very brief Sabrina
Dunlap I'm director of government
relations for Anthem we do oppose the
bill we think it's repetitive and
unnecessary but if it does move forward
we have a very small requested edit just
to clarify that the information that
comes in is the actual information that
is needed and necessary to process the
claim and I have a copy of the full 420
j8a to show you where the little piece
fits into the bigger picture if that
would be helpful but it's just one minor
change to add a word that says receipt
of the requested additional information
not just receipt of additional
information
okay
this dude yeah well it's new instead
having something over there
oh great
no now it's working
we're running late now is that am I
right okay okay so we'll open up the
public hearing on Senate Bill 99
and I guess the senator is not here but
good morning chairman hunt and members
of the committee my name is Daley
frenette and I'm the Senate majority
caucus director I'm here this morning to
introduce Senate Bill 99 on behalf of
senator rashardi
RSA 402-h colon 6 requires insurance
carriers to conduct semi-annual audits
of each contracted third-party
administrator that administers benefits
for more than 100 certificate holders
currently at least one of these audits
must be on site and Senate Bill 99 would
remove this on-site requirement
the kova 19 pandemic led to a rapid
implementation of virtual business
practices during this time the New
Hampshire insurance department like that
of most other states gave insurance
companies temporary allowance to conduct
their administrator audits virtually the
success of virtual audits makes
permanent modernization of administrator
audit laws both prudent And Timely
since insurance carriers are ultimately
accountable for the administrators with
whom they contract it is the insured it
is in the insurer's best interest to
complete effective comprehensive audits
control audits there we go
virtual audits allow insurers to observe
administrative staff where they
primarily work in the digital Realm
virtual audits are more accurate
inclusive and efficient and more
efficient than in-person audits insurers
should have the discretion to decide
whether an audit would be more effective
virtually or in person thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
this morning I will defer any questions
to The Advocates behind me
thank you okay thank you very much
Heather Silverstein from the insurance
department and is in
oh
he doesn't know anything he doesn't know
okay so do you have a question you can
ask me I couldn't hear it
no question but I'll whoever you ask me
the question ask what is the question
yeah if they want if they if they're
talking about virtual reviews right
should we be able to have the word in
here that says that okay so we now have
the insurance departments coming up okay
and that would be a great question for
you to ask her
no I understand
okay
142. okay oh I think
okay yeah that would be great
we would want to know whether you guys
are in support of the question of the of
the bill anyways
you could say you don't take a position
uh good morning
um Heather Silverstein General counselor
for the New Hampshire insurance
department and with me is Doug Bartlett
our financial director for the insurance
department uh yes you know we don't take
a position as far as this bill goes
um which is why I wasn't planning on
speaking on it and I can have Doug fill
in the holes too as I speak it is
correct during the pandemic there was
difficulty with getting audits done the
insurers are part of their obligations
with regard to tpas is that they have to
audit these tpas and the way the statute
used to read was that it was appeared to
be in person and so this change allows
it to be
um electronically which is something
that as a department often when we do
examinations of our companies they used
to be in person and now there's plenty
of times we review the files
electronically so we understand that you
can still do that
um you can still fulfill the the
obligation in electronic manner as we do
with our exams but I can have Doug fill
in more okay so I'll but I'll ask you
right out of the block doug because I
know we charge when we do an on-site
audit there's a fee we do right yeah we
I say we as the state of New Hampshire
I'm taking ownership yes yes we is in
here we we our insurance department
charges for that visit so when first
reading this it looks like all of a
sudden now we just saved some money to
that for the energy because we are not
going to do that on it but of course we
are doing that audit but you're doing
the audience this is this is the third
party person doing the insurance company
uses a TPA to settle two games okay
this law says you have to audit them
twice a year
it's got nothing to do with insurance
right okay just that uh all right and um
Revenue neutral Revenue I get that okay
just thank you for clarifying that for
me so the question then would be is
um in terms of your support or
non-support what is the consequence or
why was this why was it put in the bill
in the first place you know why is it in
the law probably written a long time ago
when people used to do physical audits
before computers inside it's just never
changed and and and uh
as Heather mentioned and the person
before me mentioned during covid
you know they did all virtual audits for
lack of a better word okay and and
they're fine I mean when we do exams
examinations of companies
we usually only physically there when we
interview management management right
and and do the management interviews and
maybe go you know a week every two
months or something just to
show a presence but but this legislate
had nothing to do with that in
particular this is just using the TBA
okay great so uh representative spear
I've found there's somebody else in the
room who will be able to answer your
question and they will be next
any other questions from the committee
members
seeing none thank you very much
okay Henry
thank you Mr chairman uh and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of the
American Council of Life insurers
uh which is the group that asked Senator
ricciardi to sponsor the bill so the
current law
requires the insurance company
to semi-annually audit their third party
administrators so it's separate from
what the department does
the statute
says that at least one of them has to be
on site
now New Hampshire is only one of 13
states that still requires an on-site
um audit
the statute was enacted well before
there was an ability to do remote uh
auditing
um now some of the tpas don't even have
office space
um they're they're doing it remotely
and so sometimes our folks will rent
some space to meet with the
people so they can fulfill the statute
so I think the pandemic proved that it
can be done this way
um and we approached the department back
in the fall I spoke with the
commissioner because we wanted to make
sure they were fine uh with the bill
um and as um was stated he said we're
not going to take a position on the bill
that's something for the legislature to
decide but you know it worked well
through the pandemic and that seems to
be where everything is headed so it's a
pretty simple bill it still requires the
audits to be done
um
they were very effective dun remotely
through the pandemic and that's all
we're looking for and again we're still
just one of 13 states that requires uh
on site gradually they're you know
removing that in the statute so
great uh we do have questions
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions
are there any requirements to preserve
physical documents uh as part of record
keeping that
may need to be examined physically
um I will ask
my person at acli I'm not you know
intricately involved in this stuff but I
will get you the answer before you guys
exactly on the committee
okay representative spirit
so now that I have the right person I'm
sorry about that uh you took out the
line that says at least one such review
shall be on site but you don't say the
line that should say it could be done
remotely so it kind of sounds like a
free-for-all at this point so should you
have something in there that says I
wouldn't have any problem I think uh
that's what we were attending uh and
assuming but to make it clearer if if
you think it should be in there it'd be
a friendly Amendment excuse me following
but if you do it remotely
you could still provide any hard paper
via email or whatever exactly that might
be needed that you were going to look up
is that true correct that's correct
okay
any other questions from the committee
see none thank you very much all right
okay
having no more cards instead about 99
maybe we'll close the public hearing and
Senate bill 99.
and we'll go to subcommittee
please
so Henry do you mind just figuring out
how you want to rewrite it so I can get
it and get the amendment I'm trying to
thanks
okay
last but not least Mr chairman did we
say we wanted an amendment I I just told
yeah yes but did
you say so you want an amendment I want
the amendment so when we went into this
committee we can discuss it
you know but that that in general
um I usually like to have the language
worked out ahead of time so the
subcommittee won't then about to have
another subcommittee if it you know try
okay
so what the one
would you too
okay
and representative Senator good morning
Senator Lang
I didn't see you be hiding behind that
speaker
okay thank you committee members thank
you house Commerce and consumer affairs
committee my name is Tim Lang I'm a
state senator uh serving uh District Two
I'm the chairman of the house Ways and
Means Committee I also was a previous
House member for three terms prior to
becoming a senator
um serving as chair of Fish and Game I'm
introducing Senate Bill 142 it's a
request of the insurance department this
bill passed the Senate on a consent
calendar with a 5-0 vote in the United
unanimous vote on consent
um Senate Bill 142 clarifies stature
which regulates forms and rates for
property Casualty Insurance the
department proves removing the phrase
Rating Bureau and rating organization
from the forms and rates law and RSA for
412 both are Antiquated phrases that are
no longer in use by at the department
the current relevant term is advisory
organization this bill also amends RSA
412 colon 16 to clarify the language
regarding confidentiality of insurers
proprietary information submitted with a
rate of rater rule filings
language change simply clarifies the
scope of the provision and was not
intended to expand or reduce it but
clarify
Heather Silverstein from the insurance
department is here to give a more
complete understanding because I know
almost nothing about the insurance
department other than they know my phone
number and asked me to file this bill so
thank you very much I'll take questions
we thank you very much for your
introduction
good morning good morning again good
morning I'm Heather Silverstein I'm
general counsel for the Hampshire
insurance department and thank you to
Senator Lang for introducing this bill
for us and being a sponsor again this
bill is I've talked to Christian cirella
he's our opinion he's our chief PNC
actuary and after
um
his practice again as we practice with
the statute in our work on a daily basis
on a regular basis there are sometimes
tweaks that we need to be made and
according to Christian
um it's you know in working with rates
and approving rates for Property and
Casualty at the department
um you know he noticed that this term
Rating Bureau and rating organization
are in our statute and we don't even
know what that means anymore it's out of
date advisory organization is different
and so that's the part where we just
want to change get rid of Rating Bureau
get rid of writing organization and just
limit it to advisory organization
because we do license those
organizations that will submit rates on
behalf of companies we allow these
advisor organizations to do that if
they're licensed with us the other piece
of this and I'm I am often drawn into
write to no requests at the department
in my position and what is permitted to
be disclosed and what is not permitted
to be disclosed and
we have different confidentiality
provisions and then one of the
exceptions for not disclosing something
would be proprietary information and
this language is just clarifying that
predictive models that companies use
when they engage in determining rates
for you know insureds are proprietary so
we are just clarifying that we consider
that proprietary we want the company to
still identify that that these are this
is proprietary and confidential
information but that's really what this
is is clarifying the rates still become
public it's not that we're trying to
hide the rate but anything that would be
proprietary like a predictive model that
really needs to be clarified we feel in
the statute and that's why we want to
make these changes
uh representative Terry can you speak uh
I'm just fascinated on the history of
ratings bureaus and advisory
organizations can you just speak uh
briefly as to uh what happened over the
the course of the years that rating
bureaus just disappeared and or did they
change their name or is this a broader
group now could you just elaborate a
little bit on that so I've been at the
department since 2015 and in my current
position since 2018
and I know that this came up in the past
where we kind of scratched our heads as
to you know Rating Bureau ratings
organization so I want to say sometime
before 2015 it kind of fell away now I
don't know if that has to do with the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners like sometimes they have
had terms Annie I see has had terms in
the past and then they changed their
terms over time which we change our
terms over time too
um to kind of catch up so that may be
why I'm not sure
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions just zeroing in on the
predictive model is that something the
department sees or they see it but they
don't disclose it to the public we see
it Christian will review it Christian
will see it when he's looking at the
rates to approve the rates but then
um just label confidential we keep that
confidential so that is not public um
and so this is just for the question oh
thank you very much uh Mr chair so the
predictive model can be like a
spreadsheet that's easy to follow or it
could be something like artificial
intelligence that's a black box to a
regulator are you seeing me I know it
means something to Christian it seems a
actuary but if you would ask me to look
at it I probably could I think this is a
great learning moment so basically what
we're talking about here is when we say
about the insurance company's secret
formula and I used to joke about the guy
with the green shade and he's the one
who uh who may look at a particular
legislation we pass and and say okay now
I need to add a predictability into our
calculation of what your premium is
going to be and that I have to rate that
risk and figure out how much or how
great it is and what it is and what is
the statistical odds of it occurring and
all of that is what is the secret sauce
of an insurance product so you always
say how did they come up with this
premium well they actually have to prove
to the Department
their logic
that's what Christian is doing he's
going to look at their spreadsheet and
the numbers have gotta he's going to
look at he's not just the spreading as
it calculations it's going to look at
what are the parameters that you're
putting in what are the assumptions that
they're making and that that's what
they're getting from the advisory
organizations who are again saying but
you know what we advise what we think
these things may be
um and and basically give the tools to
that insurance company to make those
calculations
make a comment just yes computers are
replacing the the man with the green
the guy with the green change is still
there because he's got to come up he's
got it and like you say AI
could you know could an AI uh uh figure
out what are the statistical odds or
something happens well then they have to
look at statistics calculations what
occurs but at the end of the day there's
always that human factor is do I really
think this is really gonna there's claim
gonna be made on this issue or not or
that that calculation so I I I don't
think the green shade guy is ever going
to lose his job but but yes AI could
play a part in
um sharpening his his uh his his
calculations and I will say that you
know one of one of the main things
especially with PNC because it's
competitive rates you know related
competitive rates
um
you know Christian reviews whether the
rates are discriminatory you know like
so you can't have you know a way to get
to a a premium or rates based on
discriminatory Factor so he would
consider those types of things when he's
looking at these predictive models too
it represents appear do you have a
question or is you asking a question to
the chair
yes but I'm
I don't even know how to phrase it but
what I'm asking is I I'm trying to read
this and I understand that there's a a
portion of
the predictability for premiums is done
by an Actuarial kind of calculation and
all that kind of stuff and you have a
group of people that or a person that
reviews that to make sure it's makes
sense
in this bill you're talking about
other data that is not necessary for the
calculation of policy premium
what kind of other data are we talking
about that is not necessary
so that so I know and this is from my
conversations with Christian because I'm
not an actor okay so they could be
predictive models there also could be
factors outside of a predictive model
and so Christian will also look at
factors so it's not just that everybody
would file a predictive model that you
know that's becoming more popular but
there are also factors that are
considered in individual factors
considered and coming at a rate
representative Sullivan
thank you um so do
do when when close close to the mic so
represent kids sorry
so when
when Christian or whomever in the
department is looking working I don't
know yeah it's working okay good uh when
Christian or whoever in the apartment is
looking at this and the insurance
company says is our secret sauce we want
it to be confidential
can he override that can he look at that
because I could see a world where they
just try to hide everything and I wonder
if he's able to look at like all right
this is fair this is actually
proprietary and this is them stretching
to try to just keep it a little bit more
black boxy okay so so for them for the
right to know and uh issue and my
experience with that we've had
situations like that where you know you
might say this form is proprietary and
we might look at it and say yeah I don't
think so please explain to us why this
is proprietary we have had that back and
forth with our licensees and so it has
to pass the smell test and so we do do
we do have those conversations we
wouldn't just automatically make it
public we would have a conversation with
our licensee so you're more than the
Spells a rubber stamp that's what you're
saying exactly
yeah they could officially they can
disapprove it but they'll come back and
say Okay show us your statistical
analysis to document what you you're
making that calculation on show us the
evidence that you're making that on
representative Gibbs thank you uh the
insurance department Christian or
whoever does the evaluation has access
to this proprietary information so that
he can determine whether there are any
discriminatory factors it's just that
it's not subject to the right to know
law exactly thank you
okay
okay thank you very much thank you
uh
Jim you know
nobody else no okay all right we will
close the public hearing on Senate bill
142.
and Senate Bill 198
uh uh and
excellent sorry I didn't notice you back
there I would have started sooner but
evidently there was a lot of sharing
going on here
um good after
the committee for the record I am
Senator Rebecca Perkins quoka
representing Senate District 21 the city
of Portsmouth and several Seacoast
communities
SB 198 directing the insurance
department to conduct a cost study of
providing coverage for certain
reproductive Health Care
is a simple bill that could have a big
impact for a lot of Granite State
families
assisted reproductive treatment more
commonly known as IVF is a pathway to
pregnancy and the joys of a family that
come with it for many people because
insurance carriers however typically
require a diagnosis of infertility in
order to approve a claim same-sex
families are finding that their claims
are being denied
this bill would direct the insurance
department to take a simple first step
of conducting a cost study on expanding
group health insurance coverage for IVF
without a diagnosis of infertility or at
least a traditional one
this bill is not a mandate and does not
create or change any existing insurance
coverage it is simply directing the
department to take a look at the cost of
expanding this coverage and report back
to the general court on their findings
I've spoken to the Commissioner of
Insurance on this bill and he is fine
with it
sb198 passed Senate Commerce unanimously
and passed a full Senate on the consent
calendar
and with that I am happy to answer any
questions
okay any questions representative
Burroughs
one question I'm always concerned when I
see a study or cost study are you
concerned that this could be a study to
know where or what would be what you
hope would happen as a result of that
sure sure thank you for the question
representative so my personal hope is
that the cost study would show that
expanding this group health coverage is
not that expensive for the carriers and
so they would be open to revising their
coverage to include
um
IVF insurance coverage from the same
stage as for heterosexual couples for
same-sex couples
so you do admit in the end of the day it
is a mandate for insurance companies to
so we have to have the data to make
exactly intriguing
this is not a mandate well it is a
mandate to the department for them to do
a cost analysis correct to find out how
much this is going to cost how much this
mandate will cost if we were to
implement it
yes correct chair however that second
step in that mandate is not in front of
you once we have the data and what it
would cost for that expansion then we
could all consider whether the expansion
and coverage was warranted or not right
so in terms of doing a cost analysis
how would the department do this is
going to try to predict how many couples
May
chooses
are we supposed to do analysis of how
many
gay marriages are out there I mean what
are what are they going to use for their
calculating basis and to make this
calculation how what are they going to
be what kind of data are they going to
be working from sure so there are
fertility providers in New Hampshire
um you know there's several and I have a
couple of practitioners in this field
that are here with me to testify and so
they may be able to speak to this more
accurately than I can but there's
certainly data out there on same-sex
couples that are seeking fertility
treatment and so I think the insurance
department would probably look to that
okay thank you
and do we have any questions from the
committee we do representative Burrows
thanks for taking my other question yes
I guess my question is irrespective of
cost do you believe that heterosexual
couples and and um
non-heterosexual couplers deserve the
I do and yeah so I just I figured you'd
say yes but I just even wonder why we
need the cost study I mean it just seems
like a basic right that everyone should
have
uh I would agree with your
representative but I think
um that in order to create some
consensus or understanding around this
issue that data is always helpful and so
while
um
some coverage for same-sex couples
exists in New Hampshire and the
insurance carriers will tell you that um
you know same-sex couples do have
separate procedures to qualify for
fertility coverage for insurance and so
I think ultimately we all want Happy
thriving families in New Hampshire and
so making sure we have enough
information to make that successful is
important
but I understand our infidelity coverage
is only if you're have an infertility
issue
in this case they don't have an
then they would be covered if it that
the only reason they're being rejected
is that they're not doing it because of
infertility
they're doing it because the biology
doesn't work right
so if well what I'm saying is you're
asking is does a a couple who are a
they only can get this infertility
coverage if one or the other
so as I'm saying this is that if if
you're going to ask about if if in a in
a gay couple relationship if one of them
is infertile
then theoretically they would be able to
get this coverage under our current law
it's probably a conversation for another
day Mr chair but I would argue that
same-sex couples are inherently
infertile but that may be not the
conversation of this though that's a
biology question it's a biology question
okay
representative Spears
just as a clarification and I don't know
exactly who would
Aunt uh
this kind of coverage I know with with
Mike no no with my car I got to pick
certain things that I wanted so this
wouldn't be a mandate for everyone it
would be you would pick wooden is that
true that you would just pick which
coverage you wanted and if you were a
gay couple and you felt this would be
useful for you you would pick that it's
not a mandate for everybody right
um I I'm gonna let the practitioners
behind me speak to that just because
it's sort of how Insurance operates but
yeah I mean you
are still a customer of insurance
companies and so you would still be
electing for example family coverage but
I think
um what we're hoping the cost study
reveals and what we suspect is the case
is that there's actually this is not
um
a huge number of people and so the cost
study hopefully will reveal that it's
not a huge cost even if it were to be
something that is underwritten by the
his hand up first
uh thank you represent uh Senator thank
you
my question
do you have any idea of what or how much
it's going to cost the insurance
department to do this study
there's no Financial node on it that's
why I was asking that's true it did not
get identified as an FN so again I've
I've spoken to the commissioner and I I
don't have information on that but I can
just offer that he had no objections to
including this and his work over the
next year
I'm glad you're on tape so we can quote
you on
I just have a question out of curiosity
um
the definition of same-sex couple
um I guess if you were transgender you
could be considered a same-sex partner
um I am not an expert on how do you
define same-sex couples yeah in today's
parlance yes well
um it's a good question representative I
will let the practitioners behind me
speak to how that affects this bill from
a practical standpoint
um I don't know if it's defined in law
or whether you know this would be sort
of the only language concerning that
thank you
okay
okay representative purcelli I noticed
uh thank you for letting me ask the
question I I notice it also says end
single individual so doesn't that really
open it up to
everyone and anyone so I'm not sure how
to
conduct this study
I mean it it
says single individuals
yes that's a good point and so you know
again the intent is to
make sure that our insurance coverage is
treating everyone equally
um and so again I think I'm probably
going to defer your question if you
don't mind to the practitioners just to
make sure I answer it accurately thank
you
thank you very much thank you very much
committee
you said oh there's somebody else you
wanted to speak yeah yeah sorry we we
ask you to fill out a pink card okay why
don't you fill out the pink card and
I'll have uh uh Alex Palma will come up
hi I'm Alex felvable
insurance company examiner for the
insurance department
um and
um
as Senator Cuoco mentioned the
commissioner would be happy to arrange
for the study that this bill
um
calls for if it's the pleasure of the
committee to have that move forward but
we do request uh we have basically a
procedural request there is already a
statute on the books
um RSA 400a 39b that provides that any
standing committee of the House of the
senate in when considering a proposed
mandate has the authority to refer that
bill to the commissioner who then has
the authority to retain an external
reviewer or an Actuarial firm to conduct
a study of the costs and the benefits
of that proposed mandate and we would
prefer to use that that procedure
so what that would mean was was that
this committee would just take a vote to
refer
the the review as specified in the
proposed legislation
to the commissioner under that statute
400 a colon 39- small B
um and we do have an actual reform on
retainer and it's in our budget we
usually end up conducting one or two of
these studies every year they cost on
average around fifteen thousand dollars
to conduct and the actual firm does have
to
make estimates of some of the questions
that were raised by this committee how
many people are likely to
um
take advantage of the services that we
newly available and then they would also
have to estimate the cost of those
services and the frequency of the
services in order to come with come up
okay representative Burroughs thank you
for taking my questions so just to
understand over here sorry
um so given 400a so what so you know do
not need a bill to do that it just needs
to be a request yeah it's okay A little
bit
um
unusual you need a bill that's being
considered which you have
but as long as there's a bill under
consideration then the proposed the
contemplated mandate you just need we
need a committee vote to refer it to the
insurance department and that's all we
need to move forward
follow up do we need an amendment
I generally call this the the Lismore
Elizabeth Murphy who is the lobbyist who
had this bill put in and so I call this
the Murphy Law and uh it and the Murphy
Law was that the committee rather than
uh in terms of if it would normally
either retain or interim study the bill
and that in the meantime uh the request
that the department takes the language
that's in the bill as written right and
that's very important so they're not
going to add any other variables to the
store subject they're going to be
looking at just the way the bill is
written and do a cost analysis of what
that mandate might require be right
because right
representative Gibbs thank you uh in
terms of figuring out how many people
would be requesting this coverage am I
right in understanding that there are
records
existing out there of same-sex same sex
couples and single people who are
seeking fertility treatment or have
sought fertility treatment in the last
um
the most common records that I'm used to
dealing with are
um claims files so their claims that
have been made to insurance carriers in
this case
um some of the services occurring may be
self-pay and I think it would take a
little more digging for this for an
actual firm to get a hold of those that
kind of information
uh follow-up for the question you may
inquire thank you uh
but will it be possible to obtain this
information and a sufficient numbers to
make a reasonably accurate estimate
I believe so yeah that's the whole
essence of Actuarial science is to use
available data to make best possible
estimates and this is not an unusual
kind of mandate to be evaluating thank
you
oh representative field
because you're are any other states
currently mandating coverage for uh
fertility coverage for same-sex couples
I don't know maybe some of the other
Advocates
um would be aware of that
yeah I would say that infertility
coverage is relatively new for New
Hampshire we only passed it in the last
couple of years so
it's five years five years yeah the
scheme of mandates the scheme of things
yeah
no okay
thank you very much
all right so we now have another card
you look familiar I feel like we've met
before
okay
save four years
thank you for um the committee's support
of that particular Bill my name is
Catherine
and I have an exclusively a fertility
law practice so I deal with a lot of
folks who are undergoing IVF and also
artificial insemination and other terms
other types of fertility treatment and
the bill that went through this
committee four years ago was limited to
Medical infertility so basically when
there's a medical problem like myself
and my husband we had medical problems
we had a lot of medical problems egg
sperm uterus all bad
um so we you know we were lucky that we
were able to get coverage through my
state employment at the time
um but there's still a gap of people
what we call social infertility which is
folks who don't have a partner they can
reproduce with for whatever reason
um whether they be single whether they
be in a same-sex relationship and in
terms of transgender folks this
depending on the relationship status
they're either going to fall under
medical infertility or social
infertility so we'd have to look at that
to make a determination for them but
um
the bottom line is that these folks need
fertility treatment just as much as
everybody else does and they're paying
their premiums and they're not getting
the coverage they a same-sex couple can
become medically infertile if there it
turns out to be a problem but they first
have to try treatment on their own at
their own expense in order to even find
out that there's a problem
um Maine is currently the only state I'm
aware of that provides full coverage for
both social infertility and medical
infertility there might be a couple
others but it's going to be a very small
number it's generally a medical
infertility is what the laws have been
looking at and the reason we did that is
because we at the time only had cost
data for this medical infertility we
didn't know what the costs were going to
be for social infertility we want to get
that data so we can examine what our
options are and not necessarily we're
not necessarily talking about a mandate
here one option that was brought up in
the Senate was possibly having a rider
or an acquire the insurance company to
offer the option to purchase a rider for
coverage so
it you know there's there's various
options we don't know exactly what makes
sense for the people of New Hampshire
without having more information on the
costs and this particular cost study
hasn't been done it was supposed to be
done in Maine but that didn't happen for
whatever reason the insurance
commissioner did not do a full
scientific actual Actuarial analysis and
so the really can't rely on the
conclusions that came from Maine what we
do know from prior research is that the
it yes there is initial cost for
fertility treatment but patients make
better choices in their fertility
treatment if they have insurance
coverage and that results in fewer twin
and triplet pregnancies which are
astronomically expensive one cycle of
IVF paying for that is always going to
be cheaper than paying for triplet
pregnancy and so what we see now is a
lot of same-sex couples it's on their
own diet they're making decisions that
are not ideal female couples may be
taking ovulation drugs in addition to
doing an artificial insemination which
is you know that's that's how you end up
with triplets nowadays male couples
they're obviously you know they're doing
an egg donor and a surrogate and the
male couples they all they always come
wanting you know we want a child that is
we each want a genetic chat twins
transfer to umbrellas let's have twins
well you know those costs get
astronomical too when those pregnancies
get complicated and those pregnancy
complications are going to be covered by
insurance and when the children are born
prematurely there's going to be NICU
costs and then if they have long-term
side effects there's going to be
long-term medical expenses so the way to
address this is give the insurance
companies the leeway to impose best
practices for patients who are getting
coverage and so what we actually expect
that we expect that the cost to be
relatively small and that it's actually
going to be offset by the savings from
not having these complicated pregnancies
involving NICU time and Lifetime Medical
Care
um if this is purely we're looking at
medical costs we're not looking at the
cost of a surrogate or the costs an egg
donor just purely the medical costs for
getting those eggs getting the sperm
mixing them together
putting them in a a person to get
pregnant
um
and it's really just a matter of equity
these couples are paying their premiums
and they need fertility treatment they
may not need the fertility treatment for
the same reason my husband and I did but
they still need it and so it's important
that we you know we figure we look at
these costs and then we get creative and
think about you know how we can make
this you know how we can make expand
coverage for the people of the State of
Gabe representative
[Music]
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question is can an insurance company
I know it's a company it's a you know
it's many people
decline coverage because of their
wow I I you know I think that that's
going to be an issue that is going to be
coming before the U.S Supreme Court at
some point in the next few years and
then we will have more answers on that
I'm not sure right now and I'm not aware
of any case decisions from the New
Hampshire Supreme Court on point either
thanks
uh representative
not sure how to put this in the uh way
of a question I feel like I'm a Jeopardy
now so it better be uh would I be
accurate if you just say would you
please would you believe that the The
Hobby Lobby case which uh concerned
abortion said that an employer-based
Insurance Fund
would be able to deny uh coverage for
example uh for abortion based on uh the
employer's religious beliefs so it is
possible that that similar line of logic
could apply to this uh type of coverage
as well would you believe yeah and I
also I want to clarify for everybody to
make sure you all understand this
legislation will only affect small
employers
so large employers who risk a plans to
State health insurance plan it will not
affect unless they choose to also mirror
it but this legislation and if we were
to be in effect would only affect small
employers
and I don't know
whether it would affect the individual
it theoretically it could not be under
the Affordable Care Act because that's
an expanded mandate that did not exist
when the Act was created so it would not
include those individuals either
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
uh our questions
so you said a term that I had never
heard before and I want to make sure I
understand it so that the next time I
hear it I know what it means you said
social infertility and I was wondering
if you could explain what social
infertility means and does it involve
someone of the opposite sex to be
fertile with or explain how that works
exactly so so if if your social
infertility is that you you don't have a
medical problem but there's still some
reason that you need fertility treatment
for example because you're a woman who's
in a relationship with another woman
that would be an example or if you're a
single woman who is not in a
relationship with anyone and wants to
become a single parent by choice so that
would be social infertility and they go
through the exact same treatments that
people undergoing medical infertility go
through they need the exact same
treatments the exact same tests the
exact same screening the exact same
so I just saw him clear a same-sex
couple is socially infertile
some point that's typically when they so
let's say we have a female couple
they're going to start with artificial
insemination which is placement of
Frozen sperm thawed and placed into one
of the women's uteruses if that doesn't
work after a certain number of times
then the doctors are going to start
thinking you know what there's something
medically wrong here and we can then
transition them into the world of
medical infertility at which point they
would have coverage under the current
law all right thanks for clearing that
up
no I have no more cards anybody else
want to testify seeing none we close the
we must be moving right along right
140. yeah look at that
all right
Senate Bill 235 and representative
Senator Chanley is here good afternoon
thank you very much and good afternoon
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Shannon chandley and I represent
Senate District 11 which includes the
towns of Amherst Milford Merrimack and
Wilton I'm pleased to be here before you
today to introduce Senate Bill 235 which
is relative to Services provided through
a primary care behavioral health model
um I'll start out and I I know that I
probably do not need to tell you how
desperately New Hampshire and the rest
of the country uh the crisis that we are
facing regarding mental uh illness and
treatment for to achieve mental health
um
we know that tens of thousands of
granite Staters experience mental
illness including depression
anxiety and self-harm
we've had I believe the most recent
statistics are that
um
279 people died last year by Suicide and
we know that many others consid have
suicidal ideation as well as other forms
of self-harm
access to mental health care as you know
is extremely difficult and is often if
not most often
um
achieved through primary health care
provider the primary care behavioral
health model is an integrated model that
is designed to allow psychologists to
work collaboratively with primary care
providers to deliver mental health care
to patients
um
SB 235 is designed so that Mental Health
Care Services uh
delivered through this method will not
be denied on the basis of the delivery
by their insurance companies
so I can just if we want to look just
briefly at the bill
um I can just say that uh the first bit
of the bill deals with um it's a
statement regarding the landscape in
which this bill is being introduced it
it covers some of the issues which I
have mentioned um the prevalence of
mental health concerns the difficulty
with delivery of mental health care
services and
um the insurance landscape then we move
on to some definitions regarding
insurers and care and then sections
Roman one through four are really the
heart of the matter
um you know with a few standard
safeguards in place
the Senate uh made a small Amendment and
that is found in uh
section four of Romans section 4 number
four was an Amendment added by the
Senate um which I think is really very
important to do
um I can answer any questions you may
have but I really urge you to listen to
the folks who are here to talk about
um the this delivery system of Health
Care in practice and I'm sure you will
hear also from some of the folks in the
insurance industry and um I can assure
you that there has been a lot of work
going on prior to this bill being
introduced and continuing right up until
today in terms of finding the best way
that we can address the situation in our
I guess the only question I make sure I
understand so this is a whole new way to
run the mental health benefit is that
definitely under current law it is
different it cannot it is taking place
it is occurring right now but the bill
is to ensure that
um Mental Health Coverage cannot be
denied solely on the basis of the
delivery method which is a psychologist
in consultation with primary care
so the issue is that
um some insurance companies are allowing
this now yes
and the concern is that uh we want to
say that that an insurance company
can't say no to this plan
that they can't say oh we we have we
have this old model the model we've
always used and you can they can't say
so what as a free market goes what
what's wrong with a company saying we do
cover this in another company say we
don't cover this so what what's wrong
with letting that insurance companies
be public or be used as a marketing tool
to sign up for that insurance company
based upon whether they use this method
or not well I I think that there's a lot
in that question that goes beyond
um
this bill uh
what I would say is that we we always P
this is a
probably a newer model
um an effective model and again I'll let
folks who can testify to that better
than I discuss the specifics of the
model we do we do require certain
coverage we we've done that as a state
we have required insurers to cover
certain
um
uh certain procedures certain processes
this is one of them and I think that
um this is the way we can best serve our
constituents and the people of the
Granite State because people ha are
there just aren't enough mental health
care providers in our state for us to
expect that everyone can go to
um an uh mental health care provider in
individual practice this is a way for
the primary care provider and the
Primary Care Home Health Care Home of
the patient for that that patient to
access Mental Health Care through that
system and I think that us require
saying now if if an insurance company
doesn't cover a certain kind of um
well they have to cover mental health
but have parity law but if there are
things that they do not cover we cannot
force them to cover them we are simply
saying that this is a denial of coverage
cannot be solely on the basis of the
delivery system the primary care
Behavioral Health System okay so is that
an assumption that that this method is
more expensive than oh current procedure
no I would I would suggest that it
probably is um significantly more more
affordable but again I'll let people
have we found any insurance companies
have rejected it
my understanding from the folks that
I've talked to is yes
but again I'm I ca I will let uh the
people who have been
the insurance companies maybe address
that themselves to say what the
conversations we've had
it's not so much I've heard from some
folks that this has not been covered
I've also heard from insurance companies
that they're they're kind of on board
with it in theory and I think you'll
hear some of that today
okay great if you have any questions
representative Calabro
it's a would you believe sure
having worked in exactly that model it
is far less expensive I am a QA medical
lead at Harvard care so I had all those
horrifics John it is a much less
expensive model and it saves lives
but so I'm just saying if it's if it's
less expensive yeah I'm surprised any
insurance company's not doing it fair
but we don't need a mandate if they know
that they must have a reason yeah okay
representative patusek has a question
oh representative Gibbs
thank you uh
in terms of
um
uh
the marketing model that representative
hunt uh was referring to
um and you know he makes a good point
about the free market
um in the free market in insurance but
my question is
um is it often possible for insurance
consumers uh to shop around among
insurance companies at the time when
they need mental health coverage
no they can't no thank you I I that's a
very good point Ray that I did um
I take your point
um
we aren't we can have a free market but
we also once we have agreed to a
for the small business there's a annual
renewal and for the individual there's a
renewal twice a year so you uh follow-up
question so yes go ahead um
if I am an employee of a small business
um that is in between renewable periods
and I find that I need mental health
coverage but
will be best able to obtain it through
the primary care model uh will I be able
to change insurance companies
okay
thank you Senator would you say that
it's true that it's the job of the
legislature of the state to do what is
best for the state and the mental health
citizen mental health of the citizens of
the state yes
we are we have had several bills in our
Senate this year as I'm sure you've had
in the house recognizing the crisis that
we're in and trying to figure out the
best way for us to meet the needs of our
citizens
the model as I thank you for the
allowing me to ask the question uh the
model that we're talking about
the patient would see their primary care
and the primary care would do the
initial screening
and the assumption is that there is a
mental health professional associated
with that practice that could then take
over the care if it if it's needed to do
that yes care would be delivered in
consultation with
um the psychologists and I think that um
you'll hear from a couple of people who
are working in this type of practice uh
follow on just a short for the question
so the question I have is I know that
it's very difficult it's it is pretty
difficult to get to a mental health
professional today without long Waits
and all the rest of the things that
we've been reading about so in this
model
do people you see it's it's a question
of knowing in advance that you need to
be involved with a practice
that can get you to the mental health
that you need mental health care that
you need so is it any more difficult to
get to these kinds of practices than it
is to get to
uh you know going directly to a mental
health profession
um
I do not know if it's any harder to get
into a primary care provider who works
in this collaborative model or not
that would be a good question for
perhaps one of the folks who is working
in that model
so so this is not for all primary care
physicians this is It's a model it has
nothing primary care physician no
nothing in this legislation would
require that a primary care physician
participate in this kind of model but it
would certainly be available to any who
chose to
but do so there's no requirement of any
special training or any special uh extra
courses they have to take or CEUs not to
qualify not to my marriage but Primary
Care would be working with the
psychologist
interesting Mr Mr chairman I understand
the collaborative but I've just had
normally when we when we had third party
insurance is that it we we rely on the
people's category of what they are so in
other words I guess some nurse
practitioner
is a primary care physician so that any
nurse practitioner could participate in
this program and there is just about
whether their willingness
to then work with
is
that's I just we're learning here
learning we're learning yes we just like
to remind us all that the senator
pointed out that the
bill was amended prior to passage
indicating in response to the question
must all Primary Care Providers provide
such a model in fact the language States
nothing in this actual mandate that a
primary care physician follow the
primary care behavioral health model the
actual only mandate insurance coverage
of such care if a primary care provider
were to choose to use the model so
therefore it's optional right but the
point I was trying to make was is that
is that the whole issue is how do we who
who qualifies and who doesn't qualify
that so therefore the gatekeeper here is
that primary care physician and they
would say is no I I don't want to
participate in this and therefore
therefore the whole concept that this is
a great option might fall flat on its
face if no primary care physician well
only 100 of them said no
well no I last time I checked we have a
hard time finding primary care
physicians and a lot of them are moving
on and a lot of family practices don't
have and so now you you've basically uh
never mind would you believe I'm a
little concerned whether the primary
whether somebody chooses chooses to do
this whether they would be very
disappointed if they find out that their
primary care physician is unwilling to
participate and so therefore they might
be shopping their primary care physician
after a mental health event is occurred
that is my concern
okay
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking our questions I'm trying to get
my head around the recent uh a few
questions representative Superior
started
um if I had if I felt I needed mental
health care
through this behavioral health model I
couldn't go directly to a psychiatrist
or a psychologist is that right
let's say this bill passes
that would not be that would not be
covered through
am I understanding that correctly
I'm not I'm not entirely clear on your
question like can you just so restate it
for me there's like the traditional
mental health model where you go to a
psychiatrist or a psychologist directly
because you don't need to go through
your primary to get permission this is
so you go to a mental health this is
just dealing with the behavioral model
so the primary care behavioral health
model would allow for you to access
mental the services of a psychologist
through your primary care provider but I
couldn't go directly to my well you
might be able to it wouldn't prevent you
from necessarily doing that it wouldn't
be mandated that the insurance could
cover it
no and I but I think that most people
the
that isn't a problem that most people
are facing right now the problem people
are facing is finding and accessing
mental health care services this helps
to widen uh the availability of Mental
Health Services to more patients and I'd
also say that many you know just to
touch bring us back a little bit many
Primary Care Providers are already most
many people who access mental health
care services do so through their
primary care provider this gives the
primary care provider an option to
consult with
psychologists as part of the
collaborative program
okay so when you say through the
provider there's a mental health
professional on the other side of that
relationship what is what does through
mean yes and I really do think that
you'll you know similar to the con most
of other conditions where you go to the
primary and the primary says I need to
allow you to go to a specialist so in
this case there's still there you know
you call them a gatekeeper but they're
still the person who is then giving the
recommendation who they should go to for
the follow-ups thank you so okay uh
representative Terry so so I understand
that really we're we're approaching this
from the insurance
yes that's why Direction because we
already know that doctors talk to
doctors correct all the time and refer
to doctors and doctors refer back to the
doctor so this is this is about
insurance just so that we get yeah
thank you and thank you for that
question it'll just this is the
greatest premise of this bill is that
insurance companies cannot deny coverage
okay representative Gibbs
thank you uh and again I have two
questions but they're quick ones uh I
hope
uh in terms of going directly to a
psychiatrist for mental health treatment
if you can find one that is taking new
patients
um isn't it correct that current
insurance requirements already require
coverage of mental health treatment by a
psychiatrist
in general in general
current uh
insurance coverage
does need to cover mental health
treatment by an authorized provider
thank you and then the second question
is
um essentially would you believe uh
based on personal experience of recently
um having had to find new providers uh
that while I don't know about
um uh primary care physicians involved
in the kind of collaborative practice
that you're describing uh would you
believe that it is considerably easier
um to find a primary care physician that
is taking new patients than it is to
find a psychiatrist who is taking new
patients yes I indeed would believe that
thank you very much you're welcome
um
Alex
who will from the insurance department
is left the room okay he is taking a
call okay we'll wait for that uh
uh Catherine Truman from the New
Hampshire psychology Association in
good afternoon
chairperson hunt and members of the
committee thank you for taking time
today to hear about integrated
Behavioral Health Services into primary
care and Specialty sites
I
my name is Catherine Schumann I'm a
clinical psychologist and I have been
practicing providing the evolving model
of integrated care Behavioral Health
Services for over 25 years
I moved to New Hampshire to start
working in a hospital in Southern New
Hampshire who is starting a Family
Medicine Residency training program
where I'm core faculty and I will be
training those residents those
Physicians on working with psychologists
in Primary Care while I'm providing that
Integrated Primary Care
behavioral treatment
I have also spent My Career Training
psychologists to do this work also and
hopefully we'll build that into the
primary care has become the de facto
mental health place to get treatment
there are just not enough Behavioral
Health Resources across the United
States
and New Hampshire I feel like it's
three-fold because I just moved here and
I'm feeling it
um
having a psychologist or a trained
mental health provider in Primary Care
is key
we offer treatment across the spectrum
of Behavioral Health I work in family
medicine that is birth to death
I help with everything if a parent comes
in and
they're having difficulty with
bedwetting with a child they're having
difficulty with sleeping they're having
behavioral problems they're having
eating problems or there's a teenager
where the anxiety and depression or
suicidality or an adult with issues
behavioral issues and managing their
diabetes pain insomnia depression
anxiety panic attacks severe and
persistent mental illness
suicidality
I get called in
I can spend more time with that patient
and I hope that you support this SB
oh and now I don't have the the name the
number in my head 2 3 or 235 because
what it's going to do is ensure that
insurance companies continue to support
this model in a way that makes it
sustainable it is not supported all the
billing codes are not supported in every
state you get to make a change and I
want to give you a specific example of
how this works
I do this every day
and I love what I do because I know I
make a difference this morning I saw two
patients with panic attacks of in my
case load this morning it's something I
do regularly and untreated panic attacks
often end up in the emergency room
because people think they're having a
heart attack that's what the symptoms
feel like and that comes with a great
cost
patient goes sometimes one two three
times but and they're discharged from
the emergency room they're saying hey go
back and see your primary care provider
and hopefully that primary care provider
has an embedded psychologist inside that
process or inside their system because
what I can do is go in in 20 minutes
when they come in to see that primary
care provider and I can help a patient
understand
what a panic attack is because and I
won't go into the full explanation you
won't give me that much time today but a
panic attack is your body's healthy way
of responding to a threat or stressor
and if you become fearful to those
bodily Sensations that happen when your
body goes into fight or flight it's fear
of your fight or flight response that's
actually the panic attack
but if you keep fearing it it just keeps
turning it on it gets worse if I can go
in in those 20 minutes and help that
patient understand those symptoms they
stop having panic attacks they are not
back at the ER the next week
so having embedded psychologists
immediately changes the outcome for that
patient
because they're not having panic attacks
it decreases the overall cost of care
because they're not going to the under
the emergency room and they're not over
utilizing unnecessarily they don't mean
to the emergency room
that then can focus on people who might
be dying
because you won't die from a panic
attack and all the providers involved
that weren't really helping get rid of
the panic attack they end up with
burnout
so having embedded psychologists with a
sustainable job are a sustainable job
because of finances by you supporting
this bill you're going to allow for the
people in the state of New Hampshire to
be able to get behavioral health
treatment when they need it
in a place that they're comfortable in
their Primary Care office
and you're going to decrease the cost of
care
and you're going to decrease provider
burnout in our state
so thank you I will answer any questions
you might have about this
representative Burroughs
thank you this is more curiosity
question
um can you treat these panic attacks
with medications so that you know there
doesn't have to be extended therapy for
diazepam
as a peanut does because you're you know
I haven't explained the mechanism and
don't have time but when you fear it and
you take a benzo to immediately make
those symptoms go away you have now
reinforced that there was something
really bad there and this medication is
going to make it better and you're in
this ongoing relationship with
benzodiazepine which over time loses its
Effectiveness become dependent on it and
you have more and more panic attacks and
because now you're having panic attacks
they generalize and they get bigger over
time and the person's life gets smaller
sometimes people become housebound
so thank you for that answer having an
embedded psychologist that can provide
that information is key and I train the
Physicians I work with to know that and
they go out into the world I can speak
from experience with us they end up
going because they're doing their
training in an emergency room and then
they share that with the emergency room
docs and then they stop using benzos
because they now know that's going to
make it worse for their patients in the
long run
I thought they used Xanax
that's a benzodia SP I'm talking about a
category of medications that's the
okay
representative thank you thank you for
taking my question so
um this sounds like
um
they'll be many more physicians primary
care physicians and psychologists going
into the field because they know that
now that they can partner up yeah let's
say primary care and to relieve
um some workload or just expand their
ability to treat patients in many ways
absolutely when a patient comes in and
is suicidal and the primary care
physician has 20 minutes to do
everything they were supposed to do with
that patient and because we have picked
up suicide
suicidality we can't say oh put that on
hold we'll see that at the next visit
that becomes a primary thing I'll get
called in and start working working with
that patient and if I can't get them a
safety plan to get them home and get
them into the right level of care or if
need be get them hospitalized which can
take up to three hours in my old system
where I could walk them across the
street and hospitalize them here that's
a whole nother issue
um so it keeps the primary care
physician more on time when I can go in
and do team-based care with them and
representative so again we we know that
this this model already exists correct
um and and the approach that's being
taken here is coming at this from the
insurer
um
uh providing for this model we heard
that some do and some don't correct so
would it be your testimony that if this
bill were to be enacted into law that
this would encourage more Primary Care
Providers to adopt such a system and
begin practicing it because they knew
that there would be insurance coverage
for them and their patients my general
answer to that would be absolutely yes
because what yes thank you
okay any questions thank you very much
thank you okay now Alex is back in the
room
and the insurance department here takes
no position and but will provide
information
and uh is is this something that also
would CL qualify for the Murphy the
Murphy rule yeah that was one of the
points of of information right
um this uh
piece of legislation and you know does
come into the category of uh mandated
coverage
um and it does apply to the individual
Market as well as the group markets
um so uh it does raise the issue of the
defrayal concern any any mandate
applying to the individual Market
so that might be a reason to to refer it
um
for analysis by the department
so that was one point but I wanted to
start with the observation that the
insurance department
um
has been interested in this model of
care because we have been working on
Mental Health parity we've done we just
concluded two major mental health parity
exams with two the most prominent
carriers in the state and one of the
issues that we worked on with these
cares was ways to expand and improve
their mental health networks and one of
the items we encourage carriers to
consider was alternative delivery models
such as the primary care behavioral
health model
and my impression is the carriers are
looking at it and some of them are
already are already reimbursing for some
of the services that would come out of
this model but we do have a number of
interpretive concerns about the bill as
it is drafted so I wanted to mention
those because we we would be responsible
for enforcing it so on page two
lines 12 through 15
it mentions that appropriate
billing codes called CPT codes will be
added to psychologist contracts
um
we you know reached out to the New
Hampshire Psychological Association to
find out what those codes might be to
see if we could look at our own claims
database and find out whether they're
being reversed today or not
um and we didn't get a specific answer
we got an answer today don't want to be
specific
about what codes would be included to
date but in looking at the literature we
understand that it might be for such
services
our codes as collaborative Care Medical
consultation and medical team
conferences things like that where you
have your number of providers putting
their heads together on a Best Care
model for a patient
um the
um another interpretive
a problem that we have is same page
lines 27 through 30. it says benefits
arising from consultation coordination
of care diagnosis and development of
outcome measures for outpatient services
under this paragraph
performed by psychologists shall be
subject to terms and conditions at least
as favorable as those which apply to the
benefits for the treatment provided by
psychiatrists
um and this amends a statute which is
um kind of old statute now it's about 47
years old it's the state's mental health
parity law
and uh
I cannot I don't know what subject to
terms and conditions uh at least is
equal to psychiatrist means in this
context the parity law
speaks of uh in other places the
existing parity law speaks of
Mental Health Services generally no
matter what the mental health provider
being subject to terms and conditions
that are equal to Medical surgical
benefits that's the basic idea of parity
is mental health no matter what the
provider
is treated the same way as medical
psychologists being treated
same psychiatrist we don't know how to
interpret that it wouldn't be the same
co-pays and deductibles
that's probably the best way of
interpreting it but it um
is written as almost as if it might mean
reimbursed at the same rate
um so we're not sure
um
uh so that
um I mean the part of the reason we're
not sure is this statute that this
amendment is being placed in is
um old and it uses archaic terms like
usual usual and customary rates and
things like that and favorable yes
I don't think I've seen that in a long
time yeah
um
another uh concern we have in terms of
interpretation I just said the whole
bill seems to be limited to
clinical psychologists
who are embedded in a primary care
setting and our understanding of primary
care Behavioral Health you know it would
apply equally to Mental Health
Counselors licensed clinicals social
workers
psychiatric nurses I mean there are a
number of other categories of providers
and we don't understand why it's limited
to clinical psychologists
um so uh
okay
any questions
for the insurance department yes
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um uh and again two questions but
hopefully quick ones
um
and this was a question I actually had
myself before you mentioned it but I'm
glad that you did
um would it make sense instead of
limiting
um uh Roman numeral two on on second on
the second page uh to specifically to
expert consultation by a psychologists
to include other appropriate
practitioners uh such as psychiatric
nurses and there are a couple of other
categories in there and then I do have a
follow-up question right the
um our existing mental health parity law
has this list of nine mental health
provider types so you know that list
could be used here
thank you and then the second question
involves the rates of payment
um and I'm not an expert here in the
appropriate language uh but you said
that the usual customary uh language is
now outdated the language of usual and
customary which is what I was thinking
uh is is outdated is there a language
that you would recommend so that
specific types of practitioners are paid
at the appropriate rates since some
types of practitioners may have may
normally be paid at different rates than
psychiatrists perhaps are paid
um that's a complicated and highly
contested issue under the federal mental
health parity law
um in the federal parity law which the
insurance department has been working on
enforcing
um
with respect to payment amounts the
reimbursement rate is considered a quote
non-quantitative treatment limitation
and what that means is that
um
reimbursement to reimbursement levels
can be in parity without being
equivalent
um across provider types
so what the insurance department did in
measuring parity is to compare
everything to the payment scale that's
developed by Medicare
and they have a very well worked out
payment scale that's based on
resources training
overhead costs all the factors that go
into providing care and we compare in
order to measure parity we in
reimbursement We compare
um rates the relativity to Medicare and
see it and to see whether they're equal
on both sides mental health and medical
Surgical
further question
okay it's number three now
last one
uh thank you
um so is there language that you could
provide the committee uh that we could
use to reference the appropriate payment
scale
oh
um
If This Were re-referred or something
and over time
um
uh and it were made clear that that is
actually something that was uh intended
to be addressed by the sponsors I'm not
sure that it is something that was being
addressed by the sponsors the um payment
level
I think the main goal here was to
um
create
[Music]
um
new reimbursement codes for new types of
services this collaborative care
services
and not to worry that much about
dictating the payment amount I only
asked because you asked yeah I'm sorry I
did
[Laughter]
well when we send this off to you to do
your
analysis you'll have to figure out those
parameters yeah
okay
oh yeah yeah representative
just wanted a little bit more clarity on
the new model and this really is about
insurance and claims and reimbursement
and what the patient actually has to pay
so is this
um going to bundle these Services
together so that
um in the tradition I'm trying to figure
out the difference between a traditional
model in this model so in a traditional
model to get referred and each provider
would have a schedule and their own
co-payment requirements I see something
in here about co-payments but then under
this model
the services are bundled together so
that the claims all come in together and
they're adjudicated together and the
co-payment may be different is that I
think that's pretty much right yeah I
think that's pretty much right what you
know the goal here is to
um
sort of facilitate access to mental
health people go to the primary care
providers easily they don't go to Mental
Health Providers as easily you go to
your primary care provider and you
mentioned that you have anxiety or or
whatnot and under this model it's easy
to
slide that person over to someone who's
in the office and then it's also
facilitates this collaborative
consultation for coming up with the care
plan for that patient so
um
that collaborative consultation piece
would involve a kind of bundling of
services
yes
okay great thank you Alex
uh
Mike
hello good afternoon good afternoon
chairman hunt members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in support of sb235 hopefully some of my
testimony will also answer some of the
questions that have come up am I yelling
at you I can't help
um I also want to thank Senator chandley
and the co-sponsors of this bill I'm Dr
Julie Walter I'm the director of
professional Affairs and the chair of
the Behavioral Health Care advocacy
Committee of New Hampshire Psychological
Association
as you know there are a variety of ways
that mental health and substance use
treatment are accessed
as we've heard
many patients initially present with
mental health and substance use symptoms
at their Primary Care visit what this
bill addresses that we hope addresses is
the primary care Behavioral Health
which supports and enhances the medical
team through offering consultations and
short-term treatment as Dr Schuman
mentioned to patients under the team's
care
it is one stop shopping and within this
model care can happen on the same day by
a psychologist or other mental health
licensed mental health professionals so
it's not just psychologists it's also
other licensed professionals
research has showed I'm a psychologist I
live with Statistics so I bear with me a
14 decrease in emergency room visits
it's also showed a 7.5 percent increase
in Behavioral Health visits a 12
decrease in Primary Care visits what
this research says to us is that
patients are accessing the appropriate
care rather than going to emergency
rooms when they don't necessarily need
to go there
um we also believe that this bill
addresses Workforce issues and that in
nhpa does a annual mental health
practice survey our most recent survey
the results indicate what we all know 79
percent of clinicians report often to
almost always having difficulty finding
other clinicians accepting new patients
this bill is to codify the critical into
integrated care practice to help
increase the workforce where mental
health and substance use concerns often
present first in the Primary Care
about the CPT codes we purposely have
not included CPT codes because this bill
is about codifying just like Telehealth
as a codified service
um
CBT codes are Dynamic and we wanted a
bill that captures the services provided
we did provide CPT codes to Anthem and
point 32 Health as a reference point
we appreciate the many conversations and
thought-provoking questions and
information provided by both Anthem and
point 32 health over the past year
we are not requesting to mandate
coverage we are asking that of
integrated care services are a covered
benefit that pcbh services including
both consultation and the treatment
services within that model are covered
and reimbursed fairly within current
laws and CPT codes
so again this bill is about increasing
Workforce opportunity at the physician's
office to reduce the unnecessary
emergency room visits and reduce delays
in starting treatment that can happen
with referrals
so thank you so much for your time I
appreciate it I'm happy to answer
questions okay representative spear
thank you uh just a question
so the primary care physician would be
the first touch point for this kind of
care does the primary care physician
himself have the training which with I
think we talked about that on a previous
uh
uh uh represent a person that spoke to
us sure
did they provide the first level of care
for the mental situation that we're
talking about and it may not ever ever
would go any further than that it might
not but if you have a psychologist or
other licensed mental health
professional depending on what the
primary care assessment is there can be
a warm handoff right at that same day to
the to the mental health professional on
staff so a follow-up if I may so does
that mean that we don't have the codes
uh the insurance codes
for such a handoff of even the um
primary care physician to perform that
kind of an activity
where some of the
the difficulties we're finding regarding
the codes is the consultation piece is
not all of the consultation piece is
covered
across the board like by all insurance
companies
in your experience have you seen that
there are providers that are putting in
fees for service using the code
have called their behavioral health
provider to come in during a crisis who
then have to use the exact same code and
that code is rejected have you seen that
happen there is some of that there is
some of where
it's just not being billed because in
the past it's been denied and so the
practice has now become it's some where
they don't want an extra copay and so
they won't bill it because they don't
want the extra copay thank you in this
phrase in here when care is provided
through a pcbm Model A Health Plan shall
not impose more than one copay per day
for individuals obtaining multiple
related services
yes that's what we're so it would still
be true under this bill
okay
thank you very much thank you
thank you you have written testimony I
do
that'd be awesome thank you okay I have
hello chairman hunt and members of the
committee I'm Sabrina Dunlap director of
government relations for anthem
so we have spent a lot of time talking
and working on this bill
my understanding is that the folks who
support the bill agree that the best
path forward is to retain the bill so we
can continue to work on it
um I will just list off some of our
concerns with the bill as drafted I did
sign in as neutral we are opposed to the
bill as drafted but we support
the general idea
um
so and and the folks behind me are aware
of of most of these concerns we have
with the actual language
um but there's some issues around sort
of vague terms
things that are not clearly defined
I would flag one in Roman two it says
consultation with a physician I know
I've spoken to our clinical mental
health folks and they said is a consult
where the provider sees the patient is a
consult a phone call what exactly does
that mean
um
there's some questions around
um Alex feldable mentioned section e
around terms and conditions at least as
favorable between psychologists and
psychiatrists were not entirely sure
what that means
and a couple of other sort of smaller
issues the effective date and
um the new language added in the Senate
Amendment around the ACT mandating
insurance coverage of the model we do
read that as a clear mandate so
I would just also flag that in my
conversations with our clinical folks my
understanding is the model is evolving
and I think someone mentioned that
earlier and so there is not a lot of
clarity around what the codes are
um I my understanding is insurance is
not actually the barrier here and I
think this is very similar to a
situation we had a few years ago with
the collaborative care model there was a
bill to mandate coverage of
collaborative care which is very similar
to this model it's not the same I
honestly don't know what the distinction
is
um but collaborative care model also
involves a mental health care provider
being sort of integrated in the primary
care setting and that does exist and
that is covered and I will say when that
bill came up
um we came up with a non-legislative
solution involving uh the New Hampshire
Psychological Association other
stakeholders providers all of the big
carriers we actually sat together with
the insurance department around a table
for I think 18 months and instead of
moving forward with a bill that we
didn't think actually solved a problem
we got together we talked about it and
we actually like opened up the coding
issues there were challenges around
understanding what codes are covered
where what codes are appropriate and
what situation and we actually made real
progress and collaborative care has been
adopted my understanding is it's been
adopted
um more than it had been you know before
we sat down together so I think just
sort of bigger picture
um we're not opposed to these sorts of
models we want people to have more
access to mental health care we
understand all the challenges that exist
in the state I think there's some
questions around what exactly this model
is and then I also know that the codes
are emerging like I just heard that CMS
just approved a new code in this space I
mean it's very new and so I know that we
do Anthem does cover several of the
codes that the psych Association has
flagged for us and it's just not clear
to me why exactly they're not being
adopted more
um
so I did just want to give that example
of you know a situation where we didn't
have we didn't need legislation we
actually just needed to sit down and
figure out what the Practical barriers
were
um I think that could be useful here
um
and I will just say we we have not seen
a bill like this in any other states
um and I do think we need more time to
sort of work out the language and I I
think I'm a little confused Honestly by
the bill and the way it's drafted right
now
um and so I do
you know we want to collaborate with the
psych Association and others and we
would like to continue working on this
but I think you know if we had if it was
retained and we had time to continue
talking and working through some of
these issues that would be very helpful
um so I think that was everything I'm
representative Terry just really quickly
here your testimony opens up a lot of
different questions and so I can
understand why you're suggesting that be
retained but with respect to CPT codes
um it sounds like I believe you said
that they're evolving do you look
primarily to CMS for CPT codes across
the 50 states therefore and not just
specifically New Hampshire because one
of the things that I believe I was
hearing earlier on is that there is
there are issues and concerns around CPT
codes and and I guess I'm wondering who
are we looking to for the development uh
and the the publication if you will in
adoption of CPT codes and it sounds like
you're telling me that's coming from
Washington
I think in general that is usually the
process that CMS adopts a code or allows
a certain code and then it can be
covered under Medicare and carriers
often take their cues from from CMS on
codes
thank you very much thank you
I'm shocked John you would do this to me
if I bring it in a card after I announce
thank you I just wanted to clarify a
couple of points for the record John
DeJohn representing New Hampshire's
Psychological Association and I want to
respond to a couple of comments from Ms
Dunlap as well as from Mr feldable and I
would like to reiterate what the
previous speakers have have said
regarding the
conversations with the insurers they
have we have been working for I don't
even know at this point time has no
meaning since covered but about nine
months probably talking about this off
and on with the uh the insurers and
sharing points back and forth and what I
can tell you is the Salient point is
that the insurance companies Anthem in
particular Point 32 as well have said to
us repeatedly they don't believe this is
an insurance issue
and the psychologists have responded by
saying but psychologists aren't being
reimbursed
and neither of us can get our heads
around what the issue is as far as why
reimbursements aren't happening if in
fact it should be covered
in terms of the comments from Mr
felvable this is a creation of OLS
obviously this is not the exact draft
that we submitted to OLS but when we
read it we were comfortable enough with
the language and so in speaking with um
folks Insurance folks yesterday they
raised the same two points that Mr
feldable did and what I had said to them
is that this is not intended to set
rates this is not intended to have
psychologists reimbursed at the same
level as psychology as psychiatrists
and benefits arise from consultation are
not intended to change the benefit
structure or the the plan structure
as Mr felvapable pointed out and you had
commented this is old language we didn't
ask that be put in this chapter this is
where OLS put it we are more than
willing to Wordsmith some of these areas
of confusion because we see this
primarily as a practice bill
I do know that there's there's been
suggestion that this doesn't really need
to be statute we can do this in an extra
statutory way this is very important to
the Psychological Association to have
the practice model as part of statute
we excluded CPT codes and and quite
honestly I can't plan the psychologist
that was all me
I recommended not putting CPT codes in
because that's really where the Crux of
the conversation ought to be happening
over time and that's not something we're
asking you folks to
um identify this or that CPT code we'll
continue talking with the insurers about
that we're looking for the practice
model to be codified
so that this can move forward
in ways that it does it's not moving
forward now
as far as retaining the bill the
psychologists do not currently support
retaining this bill we are asking this
bill be passed however it is my
understanding that the committee has
agreed to not exec this right off and to
give us a few weeks to keep talking we
would very much appreciate that and
we'll keep working diligently during
that period if at the end of that period
we're still trying to get stuff together
we might we might recommend retention at
that point the biggest concern though
with retaining the bills when working on
this for nine months
or so if we're going to work on this for
another six to nine months there needs
to be something that's going to be
different I think the worst thing that
could happen is to retain this bill and
come back in in November and when you
folks say to us well what are you
recommending now what's different we
don't have an answer for you so there
needs to be a clear goal that we and the
insurance companies can agree on in
order for us to support retaining the
bill so we know what we're working
towards and in that case that might be
an appropriate um
an appropriate outcome at this point
and with that I will stop talking
okay representative amen has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
taking our questions and testifying
um you mentioned that it's a practice
bill and I guess practice can have two
different meetings in this context
um and then you also mentioned model
legislation and it was referenced that
no other state had this bill so is the
goal
to take model legislation
put it you want to
create the first bill of its kind
this is what I'm hearing and maybe you
could either let me know if it's
accurate and then then when you have one
uh State adopting it you can go to other
states and say do the same thing is that
the goal the purpose of this Bill thank
you very much for the question no that's
not the purpose of the bill we we've
already missed the boat this is already
we are moving forward on this because we
believe it's a viable model and we
believe you know I represent the
psychologists that's the the answer to
Mr falbeable's question is why does this
mention psychologists because I
represent the psychologists it's not
that you know licsws could be part of
this other professionals could be part
of this my recommendation to the
psychologist was to start small
my concern was if we came into Health
which is where we really expected to be
but if we come into health or Commerce
saying we want to add this professional
this professional this professional this
professional it would be more
problematic than saying we want to add
this professional group and let's try it
and see how it works so that was my
recommendation to them
um
no this is not intended to be a beach
head where we go across the country and
get this in every state this is intended
to to introduce a model that we think
would be beneficial to the citizens of
when you said the word practice bill
yeah because you just yeah clarify what
that means just for my Layman's ears
absolutely so when I say practice what I
mean is the the clinical practice of
psychology so we see this as a bill that
enhances the clinical practice of
psychology vis-a-vis Primary Care
Medicine
that's how we see this so that's when I
so
this is an insurance committee and this
bill is in the insurance section
so we don't generally do practice
in the insurance section we usually take
a practice that occurs and then mandates
third-party coverage
which is why we were surprised that it
was vacated from Health but that the way
the bill is written this is an insurance
bill because it's in the insurance
statute
uh is there anything else the insurance
statute that's practice and not
something I mean I guess it might take
to be frank is that if it's a practice
then you're the people you should be
talking to the Board of Medicine and the
medical directors of insurance companies
because they're the ones that approve
practices they're the ones who say this
is what we're going to do it was as I
call the cookbook you know this is what
we do for each thing so to me that's the
way you go not necessarily come to us
for third-party reimburse you know
reimbursement for something that is kind
of fuzzy you need to get them to say yes
this is what we want to do
with due respect Mr chair the medical
directors of insurance companies
certainly do authorize what practices
they'll reimburse for
the legislature authorizes what
practices can occur in the state
again we this was in Senate health
it was and I I hear what you're saying
about being an insurance statute I will
acknowledge that I miss that that's
that's on me but when it went to house
Health initially
we thought it was an appropriate
placement for the bill because it was we
saw it as a practice Bill yes there are
a couple of insurance
pieces that it's commented on but we saw
this primary on this practice bill so I
will take full responsibility for
missing that in my apologies
because
ever since the first day I arrived on
this committee I've gone through every
single type of mental health practice
and has been a mandate that we get that
third party reimbursement and no one's
ever said that was a practice Bill
everybody says this is an insurance
mandate
okay thank you very much thank you any
other questions for Mr dejoy see none
I have no more cards
we will close the public hearing
we will hear from uh
Senator rosewald's staffer yes
so introduce your name please
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Jennifer
Gallagher I'm Senator rosenwald's
assistant and she has asked me to
introduce her bill because unfortunately
she had a conflict
so with your Indulgence I'd like to
introduce Senate bill 243.
I'm pleased to introduce Senate Bill 243
to create a study committee to look at
whether New Hampshire should consider
moving from the federal health benefit
exchange known as healthcare.gov
to a state exchange for people who
purchase health insurance in the
individual Market
as you recall
when the Affordable Care Act was enacted
13 years ago states were given a choice
whether to create their own exchange or
to sign on with the federal exchange New
Hampshire made the choice and I think it
was the correct one to go with the
federal exchange as a way to save money
and administrative hurdles
but here we are more than a decade later
and the industry has developed
commercial software platform solutions
that are available to States
these are market-tested solutions that
work and can save States money
in New Hampshire's case we could save up
to five million dollars a year on the
fees we now pay to use the federal
Exchange
those funds which could potentially be
matched with federal funds could be used
to lower health insurance premiums in
the individual Market
last year the Senate passed on a Voice
vote Senate Bill 121 which directed the
insurance department to evaluate the
issue and determine the impact on
premiums and whether we would achieve
better control over the insurance market
and possibly Better Health outcomes
the house Commerce Committee decided to
refer the bill for interim study and
suggested it come back as a study
committee
so Senate Bill 243 sets up a study
committee to look at the risks and
benefits of a state Exchange
thank you very much and I believe there
are some folks here that are that are
suited than myself to answer any
questions you may have thank you
thank you sorry to
take wait wait so long for you to be
able to testify but thank you very much
not a problem
okay chair we'll call him Peter bragden
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee good to see you all again for
the record my name is Peter Bragdon I'm
a senior policy advisor with Freddie's
strategies and I have some handouts too
all right and former Senate President
too
uh let's see uh so here on behalf of uh
get insured getting short is a one of
the several companies around the country
that provides State exchange software as
uh Senator rosenwald's testimony
indicated back when the Affordable Care
Act was first passed States had a states
were required to put together basically
a computer system to allow individuals
to shop for ACA compliant insurance
policies and the states had two options
they could build their own system known
as a state-based exchange or they could
hook up with the federal exchange known
as healthcare.gov and as as your
chairman noted I was Senate President at
the time when that happened I remember
it quite well and we were all very
concerned at the time that New Hampshire
did not have the resources or the
knowledge to construct their own State
exchange and in fact a few States who
tried to do their own exchange back in
the early days
spectacularly failed at it because they
just don't have the expertise to do it
But Here we are now 13 years later and
so there are 19 states that now use a
state exchange with more added each year
in the last few years we've had Virginia
Maine Kentucky New Mexico Pennsylvania
and New Jersey have all switched to a
state exchange next year Georgia will
switch to a state exchange and there's
active legislation in Texas Oregon
Alabama and Illinois
these are a broad spectrum of States
they're red States they're blue States
they're big States small states this is
not a Dr Seuss story we won't go any
further with the Rhymes uh but you can
see it's very broad it's not a single
issue and and States decide to do this
for various reasons one it can save
money uh two it can give local control
over the data and design a system that
works best for you and in fact a few
things have been seen as benefits to it
and those are listed probably on lines
uh 13 through 18 of the bills some of
the benefits we've seen in states that
switch to a state exchange are increased
enrollment and more interestingly the
enrollment that comes to them is a
healthier younger population which if
you want a healthy Insurance Market uh
what you want to have is younger
healthier people joining the pool
increased enrollment reduced premiums
economic benefits to the markets as I
mentioned with health or healthier
younger people joining improved access
to data right now we use a one size fit
all federal exchange healthcare.gov
there's at least a one month lag in
receiving data from them and it's not
anything that's terribly useful for
making policy decisions whereas if we
had control of the data ourselves we
could make decisions based on what we're
seeing in the marketplace and stronger
State control over health insurance
reform and the item I passed out there's
a quote at the bottom from the director
of the Idaho State exchange focusing on
that local control piece it's not a
one-size-fits all a good example of that
is during the covet pandemic under the
federal Marketplace this healthcare.gov
states were not allowed New Hampshire
was not allowed to increase its open
enrollment period other states that had
a state exchange almost all of them
expanded their open enrollment period
for people to get insurance because of
the turmoil in in the marketplace with
respect to covet and what they saw as a
result was as I mentioned younger
healthier people coming into the pool
which made it better for everybody so by
having some State Control you can make
the rules so that's all well and good
this is not a bill to mandate or to
create a state exchange there was a bill
last year to do that as Senator
Rosenwald had testified
and um it was deemed that that bill was
just to direct the department to go
ahead and do it if you think it's good
go ahead and do it uh and this committee
wisely felt I know there's been a good
deal of turnover in this committee since
then this committee wisely felt that
wait a minute this is not a decision a
department of the state should be making
this is a legislative policy decision
um but they also determined we don't
know enough about this yet the best idea
would be to have a study committee
formed next year to do this and and
hence this bill so it lays out the types
of things to look for
um on lines 13 to 18 look at those
potential benefits make sure that what I
tell you is true uh lines 19 and 20
should study some potential risks and
liabilities right there's always a risk
and reward situation and then starting
on line 22 and working way down just
some some special things to consider
what are the startup costs right there's
going to be some money that's going to
cost us to set this up uh some options
to offset those costs I know the federal
government provides a two million dollar
Grant to states to do their own exchange
and in many cases what you end up doing
is doing RFP for someone to run the
exchange it's usually like a five or six
year contract and allowing them to put
the startup cost into that so there's no
upfront money from the state so there's
all kinds of things that can be looked
into most of these options you see on
lines 23 through 30 are uh things that
came up at last year's Committee hearing
uh so we put them in here just to say
let's make sure we look at this uh
question was asked about well what about
states what states have switched from
federal to State have any states
switched from state to Federal yes they
have most of them have now switched back
to state but let's get some history of
it so we know we're making the right
decision but as of now there's a robust
competitive market of off-the-shelf
software solutions that can be
customized so it's not like a state has
to go and build their own exchange
there's products and services out there
amongst a variety of companies and so
anyways this bill comes about as a
result of the proposal last year and
this community determined really needed
more information to make a what what is
certainly a legislative policy decision
versus a decision and I don't think the
department wants to make that position
either they prefer that the legislature
set the policy so
um I think that's about it I'd be happy
representative spear
so there uh
there is a software which are also
involved I guess in that will set up the
exchange so my question is
the software gets tailored for this
specific state that you're in and what
the state's goals are and what they want
to do but the basic part of the software
Remains the core of the software I guess
and that doesn't change
what percentage of the software is going
to have to get tailored for us to any
state yeah you know what do you see as
your experience yeah thank you for the
question I'm not 100 sure but I I would
say a majority of the core is the same
it's it's a place that's a Marketplace
for buyers and sellers to exchange
information about their Wares and set
people up some of the things that do
change though are states determine what
their open enrollment periods are going
to be for instance uh states can
determine a lot of other various
parameters but most of the ones out
there and I represent one company that
does this there are several
um but I think on all of the core uh the
core functionality is the same the same
basic thing and then the extra bells and
whistles are things like that the state
wants to do
but I don't know much more than that but
that's one of the things that's why
that's listed in here is the ability of
the state to customize it you know to
what degree is that flexibility there
and this by the way is this would uh
typically and I I think it would have to
anyways uh if the state would decide to
pursue this then the an RFP would be
issued requests for proposals for
companies to bid on doing this so I
represented one company that does this
this in no way guarantees that my
company is the one that ends up being
selected though I certainly hope it is
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um
I understand there would have to be an
RFP so we wouldn't necessarily buying or
could be buying your company software if
we go in the direction of this bill but
just for an example and I should say I
speak from personal experience uh having
been involved with this in the federal
government if the state were to buy your
company software and if after our state
agency starts using it to um uh for a
state exchange if the state agency then
needed to make some kind of a change in
the software would it be possible for
the state agency to make that change on
its own or if or or would the state
agency have to go back to your company
every single time and pay your company
again every single time to make any
change that needed to be made thank you
for the question I I can't say for sure
but I'm going to guess that like most
types of software like this that any
changes that have to make probably need
to made by the vendor now out of college
I started a software company uh grew it
to the Inc 500 list of fastest growing
companies in the country and so I'm a
little bit familiar with the software
development process and the key to all
that is to meet beforehand and get all
your specifications ironed out in
advance so what you have is what you
want and then when the contracts come up
from renewal try and build in additional
uh would you believe uh that it is
impossible to plan everything in advance
uh and that an agency May in fact end up
working with software which is very
difficult for staff to use because it is
so expensive to go back to the vendor
thank you for the would you believe and
I do think that's obviously if this
committee was uh and their wisdom chose
to move this bill along that that would
be one thing the study committee should
look at is to what degree is it
customizable and what's been the
experience of other states with their
vendors
represent Burroughs
thank you for taking my question
um
my question is I I think it's a great
idea to study this and to see where we
go but I'm seeing that in the bill I
guess I'd like your opinion it's saying
that on this committee is going to be
somebody from the Senate and three
members of the House of Representatives
this is a lot I mean the information is
pretty detailed and would seem to need
some expertise in the field and I know
it says that they may bring people into
um testify what not do you think that
that lay people can can answer all these
questions in a committee I think the
committee can get information from
various sources including the vendors
including the department of insurance I
believe the Department's testifying
after this and there's some resources
that they have already from some work
they've already done so I think so it's
um you know if they're asking the
committee to design the software I think
that would be a different situation but
you're being asked and that was one of
the situations I believe it was the
state of Oregon uh they set up this
exchange to develop they want to develop
their own thing back in 2000 2014 and
the person in charge of was a doctor
nothing against doctors but had no
experience in information technology and
so this is really if you're doing that
you would want some expertise I do think
having served in the legislature that
this is the exactly the type of thing
that a legislative committee would be
able to do with the correct information
being provided thank you you'd think
with 424 members we could come up with
four people who could
you answering the computer it ain't me I
just sold personal computers I know I
think I bought him some stuff like way
back when way back
okay thank you very much thank you all
right
the last card DJ
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I promise to go quick it's
always tough being the last person of
the day sitting between you and getting
to go home or do something fun
potentially
um I'm gonna try very hard to not be
repetitive but
uh former Senator bragness correct I
think the Genesis of this bill came out
of the discussion that took place in the
last term
the bill at that time would have
directed the department to begin the
state down the path of a state-based
exchange it put us in a very unusual
situation of having to make some policy
decisions that's typically not what
state agencies do or at least not what
they're supposed to do that is that is
your purview
so we had pointed that out and at the
time Senator Bradley had said okay
you're making some good points we
appreciate that could you go and do some
studying for us uh and so we did and so
I've passed out the report that we did
as a department and the memo that
accompanied that report
and I guess that leads into the first
point I would make and I would just say
that we will partake in whatever the
legislature directs us to do we will be
as helpful as we possibly can
but if you're going to go down the path
of studying this again then what I would
ask you to do is to review the study
that we did and identify those areas
that you feel we did not cover
adequately or areas that that still need
further research because I think that
would make the exercise a lot more
fruitful for all of you obviously the
study was done last year it was done
under a somewhat tight time frame I
think Senator Bradley had given us about
a month or two so there probably are
some areas that you've got to look at
I would just say though that be aware
that transitioning to a state-based
exchange or a state-based model is a
complex undertaking we are as was
mentioned 13 years into the current
process New Hampshire's individual
Market fluctuates between 50 000 to 55
000 individuals it'll be interesting to
see what happens to that number as the
state goes through the Medicaid
redetermination process but for the bulk
of those individuals there's now that 13
years worth of experience with the
current system
and I think the first thing you have to
consider is are you going to be able to
create a model in an experience for the
consumer that is going to be as good at
minimum or better which is what I assume
the goal here is
and the states that I've talked to have
gone down this path have told me is you
want to go into it with clear objections
as to what you hope to achieve
so things like are you looking to
increase enrollment
are you looking to improve customer
experience those types of broad goals
can help guide you as you consider
whether or not this is a pathway you
want to go down
I don't know precisely what that would
be in New Hampshire would have to
probably take a look at that and see
where the underserved populations are
how a state-based exchange could
potentially get into those populations
um and and that would have to be part of
this work as well because you
if you're going to tailor something you
have to know what you're trying to
tailor it to achieve
um
what I come back to and again we'll do
whatever you ask us to do I think the
last key threshold question regards
liability and I know that that's
something that was incorporated into one
of the aims of the study committee as a
result of Our Testimony in the Senate
and that is obviously the the federal
government currently Bears the
responsibility for the exchange and in
transitioning to a state-based exchange
the state will then assume that
liability to produce and maintain a
system that is superior to the current
one
that's that's the goal and that's that's
going to be the challenge how you do
that
um so just bear that in mind uh as you
move forward with this think about some
of those goals think about as I said
some of the things that you feel we
either didn't cover or did not
adequately cover in the report that we
did and I think it would serve the study
committee well to incorporate those
things in to give them good guidance as
to what you're looking for presumably in
the future you'll get that report and
you may decide to go down the path of a
state-based exchange and I think that if
the report is focused on what you're
hoping to achieve it'll make that
process better for you in the future
thank you
thank you DJ
um
do does this report have a complete list
of having any where the complaints of
what our current system do we have any
handle on how many complaints or the
nature of our complaints or no it's not
issues that anybody would have no
no the study didn't get into that we
didn't have time to do all of that but
is that possible you could do that in
the next week sure well one of the
things we certainly could do is I could
go to our consumer Division and say guys
I'd like you to pull all of the
complaints that we've received about the
individual market right and then from
there take a look at how many of those
complaints stem from
something to do with the right exactly
in terms of the problem solver because I
would have to say to the whole committee
um and when I first got on this
committee we had
um
5 000 people 5 000 lives in the
um we never got I think even when we
brought back uh uh medical underwriting
I think I we didn't get even up to 10.
uh when Anthem was forced into the
marketplace I think is when we started
to Peak and they were like 12 12.5
the fact that we're at 50 55 means we
have way outdone ourselves in terms of
the effectiveness of this program in
reaching New Hampshire citizens would
you believe and would you believe that
I'm a little
skits about trying to throw out some the
baby here when uh Without Really knowing
that there's some reason fundamental
problem with our software with our
system given that success that we have
had here in the state of New Hampshire
I would believe that you believe that
that
representative Herbert
um I have a high skeptical level when uh
transferring privatizing a federal
government policy so I'm a department
and so I'm would be interested in
knowing uh or getting some unbiased
opinion as to uh how well
the existing
system has operated and and like like
the chair I
um
it will be very hard to convince me that
we should take on this responsibility
and privatize it and end up having to
pay for a private for-profit company
whereas we apparently have a fairly
decent system already in place from the
federal government
uh and so I
just just out there would you believe uh
I I would I have to do you believe he
agrees with me yeah
I agree with the charity
I've done something special today okay
representing Yemen thank you Mr chair
and thank you commissioner for
testifying to us
um
my question was about your report so I'm
fixated on the the date of the report
due in the bill so it's November 1st
2023. so just knowing the legislative
process the bill might get signed June
or July
it takes a month or two or sometimes
three to help Point people it's only two
maybe three months tops that this study
commission would have and it's only
three well actually actually this is
done because it's only legislators yeah
so and they would get it pointed pretty
quickly yeah so it just means
legislators are willing to work during
the summer oh okay okay but it's it's
three house reps in one Center yeah and
I'm just trying to figure out the
potential workload compared to what you
went through in the department how many
people worked on this how long did it
take what kind of resources did it
require
so it's a very good question so as
you'll see in the report we did use one
of our contracted folks to help us with
the report we had to do that because of
the tight timeline we we could not have
put a report of of that quality as short
as it is in that amount of time I would
suspect that a similar Dynamic would
probably unfold here the legislators
would probably call our department in
for some expertise and we would turn
around and ask our contractors for some
help as well so we'll try to move as
quickly as possible
but I think that given the enormity of
and and the number of things to consider
I don't know that you want to rush you
know I think there are a number of
different analysis representative
Herbert brought up a point you know if
you're looking to increase enrollment
and of course I think that's a goal that
we all share we want as many people to
have coverage in New Hampshire as
possible
I think you've also got to appreciate
what does that look like exactly so you
have younger folks who are presumably on
their parents Insurance until 26 or
they're in the the chip program
so that's that population then you've
got obviously seniors in New Hampshire
is a is an older state so you've got
your Medicare population then you've got
your Medicaid population and obviously
that's going through a little bit of a
transition as redetermined happen
redetermination happens so what is the
total pool of people given us State the
size of New Hampshire 1.35 million
people approximately you know what is
the pool of people that you are looking
to get because as we know the vast
majority of folks get their coverage
through their employer so what's left
you know you'll want to understand what
is that number who's going to track that
out because I remember when I was on the
board of healthy kids the last number I
heard was 120
there's 120 000 New Hampshire citizens
who had no coverage whatsoever yeah and
the question is how long ago was that
was it that was a while ago yeah that
was that before after the state expanded
medicaid oh yeah okay yeah this is when
they asked chip because you know the
kids we were folded out and rolled it
into the foundation right so I know
there's some there are some buddies out
there who've been doing the survey
because I get the survey every once in a
while they call me on my phone but you
know it so it would be interesting to
get that number also yep you'd want the
most you should be able to get that
number pretty quickly we probably could
but that's yet another example of
something that you want to want to
consider absolutely and then once you've
got that population you're going to want
to understand you know okay do we have
55 000 of those people covered great
we'll move on so what's left at that
point and what are the particular
characteristics of that demographic in
that population
and why are we not able to reach them
today with the current system number one
and then number two if you move to a
state-based exchange with some of the
modules that you can tailor is it will
it be effective in reaching those people
those are all the types of
considerations that I think if you want
to approach
whether or not to go or no go in the
future you're going to want to have all
of that information at your disposal
yeah because I always heard there was a
10 naysayers they'll just won't will do
anything but yeah I think
spirited
okay no
um this is probably just uh would you
believe but I I I I think there are many
people that are not enrolled because
they can't afford it even with with acas
so if they can come up with a you know a
you know a better alternative a cheaper
alternative but still cover as much as
you know ACA then
sure I mean if the overhead to to do it
is cheaper that's obviously a plus I
don't know how much of that would
actually work its way into premiums for
the consumer that would that would have
to and we subsidize it as it is the
state already subsidized yep you know
obviously the federal government has
enhanced the the financial supports to
people uh in recent years the state's
1332 waiver uh has been highly effective
in bringing premiums down in the
individual Market
um I I know it's a hard one for you
we're going to talk about that in a few
more years representative hunt
um
you know but you know to that point you
know I'll take savings wherever I can
find them and I'm sure that that's a
philosophy that you all share the
question is does it uh does it
counterbalance the liability and does it
actually end up working its way into
premiums in a way that substantively
lowers costs for consumers to a point
where they're motivated to go and get
coverage
okay
representative priscelli
I think that
study Commission and would probably need
some significant expertise in the area
so how much would it cost to hire the
Consultants that would be required to
really have a study that has some
accurate information that we could act
on well it would all depend on the scope
it would depend on the scope of the work
that you're looking for obviously the
larger the scope the more would be
needed I don't know what our current
line is with our consultants if you
wanted us to dip into our
funding for that that would have to be
determined by the committee I think we
would probably need some guy some
something for the subcommittee on that
subject
but this is uh we we do assess insurance
companies
and pays for this fund but be aware that
you already are potentially looking at
two bills today that will also be
tapping into that fund for them to do
that financial analysis the two bills we
heard today to use the Murphy Law
so
okay thank you so much and yes thank you
so we'll give Peter one more try
for all time's sake no
no thank you Mr chairman I forgot uh
probably the most important thing I was
looking at my notes and I looked away
and then ah I missed it so uh and
talking about the finances so uh to for
the privilege of using healthcare.gov uh
the federal government charges a 2.75
Commission on everything sold on that uh
experience has shown in other states
that the state exchanges can run for
about half of that so in New Hampshire's
case that would be about a four million
dollar savings uh the federal government
offers a three to one sometimes four to
one match if you take the money saved on
The Exchange and plowed into areas that
either further reduce premiums or
increase enrollment so we just mentioned
the 1332 waiver which is funded by a
basically a tax on insurance policies
it's possible that you could structure
something where you take the savings
from a state exchange get the federal
match offset those Savings in and not
half the tax uh all policies in the
state so there's there's some there's
things that can be done to help reduce
insurance rates for everybody including
those on the inch on the um individual
Market uh but that is there there's a
2.75 charge it's been as high as three
and a half percent
um they did bring it down and they
brought down to 2.75 so it's been as low
as 2.25 so uh there is a potential
leveraging of significant dollars that
can be used to reduce premiums or expand
coverage so just want I forgot to point
that out that's a good point thank you
okay we're all set I will close the